[Music]
foreign
how did this happen which is this this
here we are on some sort of divine
um something so everyone is there lady
in the sky maybe
everyone in this um uh place is obsessed
with you
that's been clamoring to have you on
it's very nice i'm a fan
i am also a fan and here we are so here
we go
but first i'm gonna make you give you
your own intro so i don't say some dumb
shit from you know when someone gives
you an intro
yeah and you're just like can you maybe
have said that you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah
like here's uh uh whitney cummings you
know her from the geico commercials i'm
like that's not me
i once had an intro at like a like a
show
in brooklyn that was somebody just that
was like you know her
from around you've definitely seen her
you know her from around i think about a
lot and
she's a prostitute welcome seeing her on
the streets
looking like ass yes by the way if you
don't know my credits that's fine
just be like next person very funny yeah
they're booked on a comedy you love me
please
just lie and say you love her i love her
you just lie
or just say my favorite thing to do when
uh people are really animal kind of
about
their um credits because a lot of people
like okay i need you say kroger
and comics unleashed and these nine
things that haven't been on for 12 years
and they give you this whole setup it's
like dude if if you're not funny this
these credits are not going to help you
this is not what you think yeah yeah
this is not going to do what you think
it's going to do
but uh we always change the set like the
set will be
like no no am i setting up one of your
jokes like do you
am i a part of your act now why are you
giving me all these lines no
but what we'll do is the most
disrespectful thing you can do is just
say clubs and colleges
gorgeous which is such an inside joke
you like clubs and colleges like it's
just such a dismissive
confusing thing to say i love it and
nothing like a polite burn
also when i hel you've been doing stand
up for a while now but yeah
kind of kind of yeah when i started it
was
are you guys ready for a lady
gorgeous is that still happening that's
not still happening
that's not still happening sometimes i
will because they don't book ladies
anymore
phew and i'm tired fellas i'm tired
thank you for doing the work i want to
be in the house no
um yeah sometimes i'll be like i'm the
only i'm the only sort of like
tan i'm just the only sort of pigment on
the lineup and i know that for myself
but no one has to say it
but it's like okay you you the other
friend that you have
yeah yeah yeah of anything is sort of is
busy tonight is
doing another show tonight for sure you
got me that's good that's good that's
that feels nice
but yeah that's that's been the yes i
know you
from as a stand-up i know you
from a story about where you took
edibles you did this
a set about how you took edibles yes and
i was so
fascinated by your um not only your like
delivery your cadence but also this
complete disregard
for allowing the audience to catch their
breath
which is such a fact because most
comedians try to like really lean into
the spaces and get a bunch of laughs
they don't deserve you're getting laughs
you deserve but you don't have time for
them
i think that's kind of how my brain
works like i love that she's like
performing
killing but she like has somewhere to be
after yeah it's in my bed
about the performance i just gave you
it's like because every line is
basically a joke
i i don't know try i try at least yeah i
think that's always kind of been like
my nature and i feel like it partially
arrives for me being like i don't even
know
what's funny here i'm going to throw
into stuff at you and you guys can put
it together however you want whatever
whatever works for you
yeah we're making a bit of a movie here
whatever you attach
to that is what works i'm gonna just
keep it rolling
um and try to make you laugh in the
process of it i think my first
set i remember especially those ones
when it's like you're
you feel kind of new and you're like
just like especially i was like i have
to have a clip
i have to have something that is funny i
felt this pressure to have
like jokes and like jokes jokes jokes
and then i remember for that set
i was like i already stressed out about
that i want to tell a story
about something that i think is funny
and like some
like a moment in time where it's like i
don't know i loved
telling this especially in a longer set
like to break it up and yeah to break up
tell everyone just what it is for who
has not seen it do the entire bit
verbatim this is a set
dancing um yeah it's this it happened it
happened to me
um i was out in l.a one night and a
friend
convinced me to take an edible i'm so
i'm 51 days off edibles and
and i am actually i salute you you are
the troops
to me because it's i don't if you have a
short attention span or get bored easily
or are very results-oriented it's not
the drug for you what was the joke you
said you
have to wait anywhere you take an edible
and then you wait anywhere from an hour
and a half
to the rest of your life yeah you're
just waiting for that shit to hit which
made you so much more anxious
yes and then it makes you even it's just
like it's such a shit show no it's cr
it's
really um insane and it was like this
breath
miss that you like sprayed also in the
back of your throat and i
am like you know very much like
overachieving
like gifted class type of child so i was
like oh it says two for beginners let's
do four
i need to be the valedictorian of this
weed spray yeah me
yeah i'm a tank yeah welcome post i've
got it put together you just heard my
voice crack you know so
i was like ready to go i wanted to do
the extra credit and
um with my friend and
um just proceeded to like suffer um
you set up a quora account yes during it
yes hold on real quick about core is
korres still happening it is still
happening because i still get emails
from quora from a quora digest
but i don't think that i still get like
notifications from ask
jeeves i don't think it's a functioning
site cora like you have to put too many
passwords in like my
i feel like my first question of course
i was like what the fuck is cora how
does it work
why did i get to
there's probably some is there an
australian like animal that's like the
quora
you're brought an australian friend here
don't you think
it's quokka okay
i'm obsessed with the story and i need
to like break it down yeah like
clearly here i am so you do do edible
still um
there was definitely a period of
quarantine where i was like
of course in a core team um
i'm from boston so i don't have to i
don't ca i never have and i never will
um in quran where
i was probably doing like an edible
every night
and so i would like watch
i actually really ripped it to justified
and that is sort of
a scary peek into my mental
everything this is my favorite tweet of
yours that i have seen
it is so ridiculous and made me laugh so
hard
and and my guess is it got a lot of
likes obviously but my guess is no one
except me really understood it like i
have this theory that i'm the only
person that gets your tweets you
probably are
you probably are i have this thing where
i'm like talking to me i
there was like an early day the early
days of twitter i definitely was like i
want to do jokes and now
i'm like i want to be weird for myself
and if anybody else sort of catches the
ref
if you get it you get it then you get it
that's a gift between you and i
it's personal it's private this is a
tweet uh
like earlier about like going to canada
like before the election or something
when people were joking like i want to
go to canada or something like that yeah
you know people go if you hated so much
leave that's what everyone said so you
started with if you hated so much leave
bitch i'm trying if anyone needs me to
play a stupid american
oh sorry that's either the bat in my
house or an alarm i'm not sure which one
good if anyone needs me to play a stupid
american let me know and let me out of
here i'll do a spot on letter
kenny i don't give a fuck
and then the dude who made letter kenny
responded
yeah and he was like do you have any
pitches
to pass that was i used your show as a
punch line
i really don't want to be on it you hire
me
i would get on letter kenny i respect it
made me laugh sorry because it was such
a deep cut and i had just heard of that
show like
like because the guy that i'm dating
like watches it and
it's a rough i couldn't i didn't get it
i was like i need you to turn this off
because i'm unhappy it's very much a
show for guys that you're dating
okay okay but i love it sunny always
sunny in philadelphia
and usually guys love that show and i'm
fine with it i'll fuck with that show
like i love those guys but letter kenny
i was like
this feels sexist and i don't like it
please have something a girl on here
something it was all about like fucking
girls and i couldn't understand what's
happening and i was like
was this made recently like i couldn't i
spent so much time trying to figure out
when it was made under what country
circumstances something where you look
on the wikipedia and they're like
actually all these scripts were finished
in 1997.
you're being stuck in development health
for 13 years
now you're the one that has to be in
hell and watch it i'm sure a letter
kenny's fine i just was like i was
watching i was like this just isn't
maybe i'm too old to get this
yeah and i've never really thought that
before and we're writers we know i'm
like who wrote on
it like i feel like i would know
yeah i think canada is also like a
different beast i feel like it's a
canadian
it's a canadian show and there's just
like a whole different
and since there's such nice people
having a show where people are like
scummy
yeah it's probably refreshing and cute
for canada yeah they're not there's not
like truth in it or something
it's a complete fabrication yeah okay
that's why because it's a fantasy
because i was watching letter kenny and
i'm like this is just a comedy store
hallway
yeah i feel like in in in canada it's
marketed as like high fantasy like
sci-fi
they're like this isn't this can't be
true look imagine if a man like was a
scumbag
it's star wars but comedy canadian star
wars is just men not being polite
that's their fiction like a man like
cheating on his wife yeah they're just
in the room like this is so crazy
that's like avatar i'm obsessed with you
for so many reasons
and this is going to come off wrong
especially given uh
what a lot of people in my business have
been cancelled for so i'm going to say
this please don't take it out of context
i love really interested in what this
sentence i love
young female comedians there it is i
love young girls
and i love talking to them i'm so sorry
but this is love it's not lust it's love
it's a different kind of creepy
yeah i know for sure i'm just obsessed
with like talking to
the next generation of comedians because
i'm obviously
like as you keep talking your skin only
gets like more bright and like more
luminescent and plumper and i'm just
like whistling away yeah no the um
chair you're sitting on is uh taking
your blood out of your body yeah
currently no i'm definitely
oh did you drink some of that water yes
we're good
so like i'm just so curious like what
and because grace and i who's grace is
25 and we
we i don't say we disagree on a lot of
things we just see things
different we're very similar but we're
just like
if i was 25 that's what i would think
and i'm 38 and they're just there's like
what do you
what is the most annoying thing that
that us geezers do
um you're not a geezer i know but i just
wanna before i even start no i'm
thinking
i just mean like i'm 38 like just the
things like because there was the
generation before me i was like oh what
i was gonna
talk about like your husband who cares
what's your life talking about
you know what i mean like just the
things that whether they're i feel like
definitely this painting
or like painting a picture of like my
generation
as being like sensitive yeah sensitive
like hippies
almost yeah yeah yeah like who i don't
know
it's like oh you think you're the first
to think let fucking love you
freaking beard wearing hipster dipsters
literally my whole new hour
and i think there definitely is some
truth to that like i remember even a few
years ago like i just think about myself
online just there are tweets that have
been deleted for sure
like what where it is where it was just
me being like the first person to think
like oh you just wait for this take baby
like i've got
i've got it and it's like well anyone
should get paid
yeah it's like we've been trying that
for a while it is it is interesting and
i mean even things you know i
am oh my god you know i'm a black woman
and so there are moments about like
or just opinions i've had about like
race and like representation where it's
like
oh nobody gives a shit and every and
everybody's just sitting on their asses
and nobody cares and i'll talk to my dad
and he's like what are you like what are
you talking about literally what are you
talking about it's just like
your generation has gotten a lot of
things done and has amp things up and
i think have we've always been able to
use social media in a way to amplify
things but it's like it's not like
nobody cared before
but i also think i do definitely think
that it's like just because it's not as
bad as it was right doesn't mean they're
still not
bad to do also i think to me my main
thing is like as someone that in my 20s
was like i'm gonna like i'm gonna change
the world and i'm mad at everything but
it's sort of like i do see a little bit
just tell me if i'm wrong like i want
you guys to just tell me if i'm
totally off face which is that i do
think there's a little bit of like of
like emotional perfectionism
happening where there's this bar being
set it's so high
that i promise you guys are not going to
be able to live up to the own bar that
you set
i feel that even with myself even even
in the past few years where i've talked
about this with
other friends where like i don't know
i've just had moments where i now see
kids who are like gen z
and i'm like wait a minute like whoa we
just like just slow down a little
yeah like also even where i just see
friends who are a little bit younger and
it's like oh you're posting like
every single thing about your life like
every single
achievement and it's like you know some
of these some of these
stuff there's gonna be some
disappointments down the road i'm
suddenly a hundred and i feel like i'm
104.
yeah yeah but it's like the kind of
thing where it's like i'm always just
trying to figure out like what is the
difference between like being
ignorant and being having like a like a
sensible take on yeah like like i mean i
even feel like i've
seen things where i'm like
i i the me too era i think is something
that like perfectly
exemplifies this where like i remember
feeling so amped up about it and feeling
like there was going to be like these
huge changes coming and like even you
know things were coming out and it was
like these are the hard lines
this is what it is and then it's like oh
wait there are gray areas and there are
things that we don't understand and
there are things that are also like
complicated and involve like emotions
and i think
to to all things like you know me too
and different you know and
sexual assault and sexism and then with
the with the me too stuff i was talking
to someone the other day
who's like you know sexual harassment is
like in the workplace like it was
totally fixed by me too i'm like
you know that's because no one's been in
an office for the past two years he's
been in our house
dumbass i remember being in the car with
my dad like you know
sophomore year like back from college i
mean like it's so crazy what your
generation had to deal with with race
and it's like we're basically done you
know and he was like huh
what are you talking about and i was
just like all my friends were all
different races and it's like you know
it's like you
just wouldn't have been even able to go
to school with your my age and he's like
how old do you think
like what did you think my life was like
and and then you know flash forward to
this past summer or it's like we're
in the streets like still fighting for
the same things and still having these
conversations that i haven't had for
decades is like there's a lot of work
to do a lot of work to do and i think
also like
as comedians because i even feel like
this
in some of my early comedy where i was
like i feel like i have to address this
and i have to address this like in a
very
um explicit way almost and like if i'm
talking about race and i like have to be
making jokes about race and now
as like my you know how i want to
approach comedy has changed and also
like how
now i want to write things for myself as
change i'm like i don't want to say this
as maybe um plainly as i thought that i
needed to say it right and
actually you know my audience isn't like
just finding this out for the first time
like maybe i
was i mean here's the thing and this is
not like obviously i can't identify
you know as as as a black woman but it's
the kind of thing where it's like sorry
look i i mean look i huh
i can show you my old black face
pictures i i
because i you know i want to do an
episode where i go over all my like
blunders in the past there is a photo of
me at 21
i was probably 20 for halloween i went
as a geisha
i had seen miss saigon now you're
getting ahead of it i'm just saying
i ate is someone's gonna find this photo
at some point
and it i loved
memoirs of a geisha i love i was 21.
i was i i didn't like i didn't do
like anything like hey you're paying a
lot of anything
you were celebrating the best picture
nominated
[Laughter]
so it's like i was 21 and like i was an
idiot like
so to me i i didn't know like should i
have known like
probably um but i guess it's like like
you know i think everyone's kind of in
this place it's like what do we forget
what do we not forgive i'm not saying
that's forgivable
as soon as i find the photo i am going
to be showing it because i did put tiny
lipstick to make tiny lips i mean it was
i worked
i worked hard to make that exact i can't
really relate because i've just met i
just
think i've all i've always known and
also i think i went to high school with
like a lot of asian people and some of
my best friends are asian so i think and
they're like we don't like that i just
feel like it was never really in the
cards
but i did dress up as a janitor
from from from from uh like eighth grade
or ninth grade i dressed up as a janitor
named preston
so i mean like he could personally
cancel me yeah
that was if anything that was just i do
like the the halloween costumes that are
just kind of like pajamas
like that's just smart i did work i did
draw a beer i worked really hard to draw
like five o'clock shadow i stippled each
each little stubble i did it and my dad
was like
we need to have like a talk like is
there anything you want to tell me
i was like i'm preston today that's all
you need to know
daniel day-lewis in character absolutely
like he's like i think can you check out
the trash you're like no
it's my day
you know the president never has very
strong boundaries i'm sorry
preston does not bring his work home
with him
oh look like i just feel like what we
have an
absence of is people like my age they do
just saying the dumb shit they did and
just going i did because everyone's like
i never did anything
right right anyone my fucking age has
done something
ignorant yes and to for everyone to like
pretend that they're pr
this is the people that get i think hit
the most yeah when it gets the cloudiest
whenever i was like but i'm perfect and
i always have been and then someone
finds a photo of them right
now tap apology and it's like notes app
from typing on your little notes app but
it's gotten to the point where i feel
like
almost a version of like you remember
that cat that could smell like when
cancer patients are gonna die yeah yeah
i feel like that with people who are
about to get cancelled
three people who i was like i could
smell this like i know that this is
gonna happen
because also i think this is my theory
about cancellation
like and and this is just my theory
that what's what we do here i basically
this entire podcast is me saying
something that is really wrong and then
defending it
good i think people
get can't like the reason why they
actually get cancelled
is because people are annoyed at them or
you're
already they're looking for they're
looking for something to go on and this
is not to say like
when people get um criminally arraigned
right
then that's a crime that's different to
me from like cancellation like if
somebody does
crimes they're not being canceled that's
so true
that's so true that's people are like
when cosby got cancelled
he went to jail yeah there was a tribe
there were arguments back and forth and
a verdict was passed he was not canceled
different things
he is old and imprisoned right
but like i think when people do you
remember when ted bundy got cancelled
that was crazy so crazy when osama bin
laden got cancelled
it's a different thing at night too you
know
seal team six uh
but i but i think when people get
canceled it's because like
people are starting they're like
something is happening and i don't like
it so i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be searching the old tweets
and there's been some kind
of like we're all i feel like we all are
so
disrespectful to the science around like
our instincts
and how wired we are to be able to like
smell a rat
yeah there's a lot of things they're
like i don't like this person i don't
know why
they're i don't i feel like they don't
do the right thing when no one's
watching i can't articulate why it is
but we are wired to have like gut
instincts just like
weird energy yeah sir lester had a tweet
that i've been thinking about the other
day like so much where he just was like
we are in the golden age of scammers
and it extends to personalities as well
and we're ignoring those instincts and i
think
also maybe even uplifting scammers
because we want to see them fall a
little bit
there's like a woman sort of like lions
in the coliseum
we want to buy the snake oil so we can
then be victims who got screwed
by buying the snake and then we all
enter a class action lawsuit against
snake oil eventually
people love being victims it's an
addiction adrenaline makes dopamine so
people
love in a way if they don't have real
problems they kind of like being harmed
yeah yeah like i see a lot of like
circus of it and the drama of it too
is so addictive addictive yeah and like
fascinating to be a part of but
i don't think we're at the point yet
where it's like are we ready to learn
the lesson yet
okay we're just going to do this like
like i just sent a tweet we're good now
i don't have to
change i just sent the tweet or i liked
someone's twitter i sent the tweet and i
and i liked all the like good tweets so
i'm learning
and then i made a donation and then i'll
be quiet for three months
right then yes yes and what's the next
like trendy
cause i read because self-righteousness
is a legitimate addiction yeah
a lot of people on twitter like have and
they don't even understand right because
it's also like if this person's so awful
why are you dedicating your whole day
to hating them like it's just a wild use
of your energy but
and also malignant narcissists the only
way to get them to stop being around is
to ignore them
you know this is the thing that i feel
like i've been like learning
um geraldine my friend and i were having
this conversation
uh in the car where i was like there's
people that i don't like
and i think their opinions are wrong and
i know that it's like when you quote
tweet
the bad tweet and it's like more people
see the bad tweet and then engage with
the tweet
it's like if you ignore it
you know obviously there's a certain
level of harm yeah or whatever where
it's like
if this is festering you gotta call it
out you gotta say four likes leave it
leave it leave it let it rest keep
walking
just go on buddy my friends the time
that you're gonna spend retweeting this
and checking to see
and like that like you could have
written an original tweet or i don't
know
i learned like a new language or
something complete a language level on
duolingo yeah yeah every time you want
to retweet
something with like four likes just go
donate five dollars
yes yes it's much easier like it's
you have to punish yourself in some way
i have to do that shit where i'm like
every time i
like want to do this who was it that um
had a
an envelope full of like five dollar
checks
to organizations that they didn't like
so like like
like like the republican national
convention if you're liberal and every
time you
get you have to mail the chat that's so
funny it's a way to stop yourself from
doing like
basically emotional cutting like that
kind of like self-sabotaging behavior
something like that no because what's
going on with you
when people would like retweet i mean we
were just talking about this with elon
musk like when people were like
retweeting elon musk tweets to me like
fuck you alone you're trash it's like
he didn't see it you're not a hero the
man is like a sent to billionaire
you're not brave he's got like jet shoes
to go on in his house
he's doing other things and it is this i
think this feeling of like
i am um resisting like doing something
brave and oh my god
because also everybody else who is like
feeding into that same vicious cycle is
like
liking your tweet and then replying to
your tweet and it's like oh yeah a bunch
of
revolutionaries or whatever and it's
like that's not what's happening it's
people who already follow you that
already agree with you
or muted you a while ago yes there's
this false sense of like bravery on the
internet
that is just sort of like i don't think
that you're accomplishing what you think
right i mean even to a certain extent i
don't know how much like you've dealt
with this but when like people will
like you know they say like horrible
things oh my god i get unanimous
love and adoration only yeah no i did
that
i'm sorry only sort of imagine um
imagine being a comedian that got
dragged online just for any reason
let me just like go through my photos
yeah uh cue up my better help recordings
um no here's what i will say i i mean
female comedians are
truly i always say the most hated
species on the planet
it's kind of shocking it's like the most
hated like whenever someone's like
should i be if you a comic i want to be
i'm like yeah totally please
but just know that you are all ready
before you speak the most despised
like type of person on the planet you
don't have to be in therapy now let it
build up
but um at a certain point send that
email
just know that we are wired to go okay a
woman is going on stage with a
microphone she's gonna talk for an
hour y'all have to shut up you're not
allowed to speak right at all if you do
someone removes you not only that you
have to pay to hear me lecture you
and tell you i'm right like we're not
wired really for that a guy once sent me
a dm
and i just was like i was so bored that
i had a conversation with him
and he was like hey i just want to let
you know your comedy does nothing for me
and i really don't think you should do
it and i should
stuff like that i want to go like oh my
god dude thank you for telling me that
like i think you're oh my god you're
right i should
quit i said i dm'd back and i was like
hi why would you say this what if i
showed up to your place of work
and said like oh steven shouldn't be
doing construction today
just stop the boots like um i don't come
into your place of work and say this
also what would you suggest
i do yeah and so we had to actually
pretty much i love engaging with that i
love engaging with that
where he was like uh i didn't really
think you'd respond to this and then i
was like
so why did you send it that's a diary
entry that's a jog in the park
right that's a thought that just goes in
and out because i don't have that
impulse to also like
comment on people that i don't know
stuff
here's what i'll say and if you haven't
if you haven't let me know this is what
we'll say
if i was like 15 yes 14
15 sort of like in what we didn't have
like you know
i literally would say myspace we don't
have any of those friendster myspace i
was a teenager before friendster i
believe
right so if i knew there was a direct
line
yeah yeah yeah to communicate with
someone that was famous
right and that they might see it
oh i mean i i mean i'd be dming arnold
schwarzenegger i would be like you
fucking loser
i'd be doing that like i would have been
i'd have been hey
dan quail you saw i was i would have
been a troll
get his ass you know what i'm saying so
when i when these people are commenting
i'm like i need to kind of know how old
you are i need to know where you're in
your life
right to know if this is lame or not
because you might just be we just have
to
throw eggs at people's houses when it's
a team it's like that's
the you have it eggs at home yes we used
to egg people's property
now we they send a dm that that i may or
may not see
i'm like okay i like this better than
people that are interesting if you think
i've done i i definitely believe egging
rates have gone down dude
i'm just saying yeah there's things to
do stay focused this is progress
yeah you can have like a full life
online i mean especially pandemic
it's like you know i would just probably
be sitting in the cvs parking lots with
my friends
that was kind of like our thing but
here's think about like when you look
back at like when you were like setting
goals for yourself
my whole thing in life is telling women
in their
uh 20s that it's not as bad as you think
uh-huh
because i see so many women like
struggling in their 20s i did i made it
so much harder than it needed to be i
over
thought things so much and i'm so
desperate to go like no no no like
learn from my mistakes like the person
that's sending you a nasty dm that
person loves you and hates themselves
they don't hate you yes they love you
yeah yeah and they hate themselves
i do think sometimes they do don't they
don't like me but
yeah i definitely agree with the hating
themselves yeah for sure yeah yeah
they're
they're buying tickets they added to
whatever streams it was like
when someone's like you that wasn't
funny i'm like you watched it thanks
right
i remember i never promised that you
were going to like everything
i do that's not part of the package i'm
making this thing for you that i think
is funny
right you can watch them not like it i'm
not allowed to make you like it
right it's also like i don't think i'm
god i mean i know that there's like
comedians and artists who definitely do
but i know that i don't and that's why
you're funny and well thank you very
much i'll try it but um
the funnier comic thinks they are
usually the least favorite the lesson
any any comic that comes up stages like
yeah
fucking crush terrible any comic that
comes on stage after killing it was like
oh that was a fucking nightmare yeah i
don't even know i got so lost like
that's
that's a comic and and hey well the
self-doubt's working baby
so sorry so you were saying about the
the dms and stuff oh but
actually actually to be honest i almost
remembered the sentence and i just lost
it so welcome to the podcast mostly i
guess this is me going
thank you if you can finish what it was
i will not do anything i'm not too
excited to talk to you i know i'm
this is fun i feel like we're puppies
that just got to like play for the first
time i know it's like sniffing each
other's sort of um
mental butts if you will and if you want
then you want
fun who um okay i have so many questions
yeah i love your podcast and i love that
you are
like talk about celebrities yeah yeah
it's fun
but like is do you ever worry like what
if i'm gonna work with this person
or like um that would be very hopeful
of me but also in terms of the guests
that people have brought on
it would also be like what if i worked
with the real housewives of atlanta
but you know i was listening where you
were talking about sandra bullock's like
you guys
you kind of dissect cur explain kind of
what you do on there
me and my friend olivia basically
somebody brings on a celebrity that they
think is an icon and we'll basically go
through their whole career
yeah go through um their personal life
as well that's
interesting and just sort of talk about
it and then the main question we ask is
like
will this person be an icon will their
legacy
and their body of work endure uh yeah
and so i think because we kind of come
of it
from a place of like respect
yes yes like we're interested in these
people are interested in these careers
and like
on the serious level of it olivia and i
kind of came up with this because we
realized like especially as
we were both black women and we both
went to nyu and i think both suffered
from a lot of imposter syndrome
of like not being like um you know the
like children of like a producer or a
director
you know my mom works in special ed and
my dad
like works for the government yeah
drives uber
i mean truly i remember my dad being
like because i i
also both my parents are immigrants and
i had this like whole sort of complex
where i was like they would never accept
me if i do
art you know and my dad is like bitch
i've seen you writing skits
when you're in third grade like i went
to all your improv shows
in high school and like in college like
yeah i knew you were doing art but he
was like don't expect me to pay for
anything
yeah i literally will not help you so i
think that kind of amplified like
the dream like the first rule of improv
is yes and
you're bad at improv so try again
i've got concerns have you seen the way
i dapple on a mustache i'm gonna make it
there there's promise here good sir um
but for both of us i think that
definitely amplified that drive
and it also pop culture kind of became
currency for us and we wanted to be to
know things we wanted to keep
up in addition to already like you know
loving what we do and why
you know and wanting to do it it's like
you know
when you know shit what can the son
who's of you know i don't know the
director of spirit you know
stallion or whatever like what can he
say
really like when it's like actually i
know my shit i'm on my shit
and i deserve to be here as much as you
i love that you say that because i
always felt like i was so clowned on in
the beginning because i was like a
student of the business
yes i always knew who directed
everything who represented actors there
used to be a website called who
represents which when you type it out is
horror
it's kind of funny like my own little
funny joke um for myself when all i
would do is google who represents who
and then i go oh he also produced the
movie so if you have a man okay managers
also produce like i was obsessed i knew
every name of every producer every
casting director who they had worked
with like
and then i was like oh casting directors
they work with the same people every
time so if you audition for them and
they like you they might bring up
like i was all day every day and i was
like wouldn't you still like bit so in
the business she's like networking i was
like no i just i feel like i need to
understand how this machine works right
in order to understand like my place in
it
i think especially when you're like you
know you're a woman you're a person
called you're
you're marginalized in these senses it
is like it is kind of built for you to
not know yeah and it is kind of built
to be confusing yeah and to have these
barriers like
i mean i mean they're for everybody
experiences them but it's like
if you're so and so son or you know you
like
your neighbors with this person growing
up it's like kevin you
you kind of do have a bit more of an end
but are you so
glad that you're not like that is the
100 my life is like interesting
it would be so it's so hard to like hurt
my feelings like
like the only things you can say to me
because there's a certain point where
you're just like thinking there's you
can't
yeah you know and i've like lost family
like when you go through like re like a
losing a parent
like it's just sort of like nothing
hurts anymore yeah and so
i sort of uh uh i'm invincible in a lot
of ways uh
to your whore your bus i've heard that
shit my whole life you're ugly about
this
or whatever all the comments yeah i know
where my big teeth come from yeah
uh and and and and listen i could go
home to a thanksgiving dinner and hear
it
so like we're good and here's the other
thing i'll say like good one
like i agree like most of your insults i
agree with
you now what also some of them i know
they're objectively wrong
somebody commented on a picture of me
and they were like
good luck getting out of boston looking
like that and i was like i replied and i
was like i did i went away
i'm on television i know that i did
because you found my instagram like what
do you mean you know exactly what
happened
like i am a writer and i haven't hired
from multiple television so i do just
want to like track the logic of this
just like help you sort of punch up this
job why just like you told
like i don't know what web browser
you're on but i'm just i'm trying to
help you insult
you me why don't you just call me the
ugliest person on this show like at
least get your insults accurate get them
accurately totally sharpen them up so
that's why the other thing is like you
know that you're
trying to insult someone who hates
themselves like what this is like oh you
can't
what are you gonna punch oh you know i
would say
melting candle i wouldn't say like old
dusty candle like it's a melting like
i will make your uh mediocre quip a
great roast joke
yeah like i know my teeth are big but
like but the smile is great i mean talk
about how they're crooked my bite is not
aligned right i have to wear a night
guard
get there yeah get it there so come
start spying on me to get the real
intel you know so it's like give you my
dentist info she'll tell you
his teeth like four seats you know her
job
this isn't my failure i know honestly
where i get hurt and it's probably my
dad's doing these comments so
now i'm putting it
uh together a fake name to try to get
you to fix your teeth so you can make
more money and by the way are you
flossing every night
it seems like you remember once twice a
week best
feels like when you go away your gut's
gonna be bleeding you'll be feeling real
bad bitch
also why are you always late to the
dentist so you make an appointment for a
reason
somebody's place of work respect people
you always ask for a pen you're always
on the phone when you're in the lobby
like
i don't know and you can make small talk
with me that's how
and you can never make an appointment
six months in advance because you don't
know where you're gonna be
we get it you're an actor oh but we have
to call you now
got it by the way the deadline that has
something to say
i love the idea of someone fake trolling
to try to help their business
it's gonna help you and the rest as well
yeah
i'm gonna start going on and just be
like well if you were just going windy
cummings podcast maybe people wouldn't
hate you so much
that was who was it you know i think was
howard stern there was that leaked video
where he was like
he was like why don't we have lady gaga
and they're like oh we're trying like
just make a bunch of fake
handles and tell lady gaga to come on
howard it was kind of genius it is
it was just like yeah business is
business like pressure from the internet
is what works completely yeah
come to brazil i have a
facial hair and chin issue my lover
recently pointed out to me that i have
a goatee and salvador dali mustache
but i don't like shaving my face because
i feel like i always get zits billy
razor
not a zit in sight look at my uh look at
my lack of a moustache and i can even
shave up against the grain and it
doesn't make me look like i have herpes
yeah here's
my deal i never used uh
what shave gels or shaving creams or
anything shame creams that's
i didn't i was like too such a rigmarole
and it doesn't even work and then
this stays for so long and it's got aloe
vera and stage so afterwards i don't
have to slather on some
you know uh lotion to fix all the
dryness from the thing and the razor
yeah
it's perfect to express a little love
for our show go to mybilly.com
whitney it's a small way you can support
us while getting the best razor you will
ever own it's just nine dollars to get
your starter kit plus free shipping
always
go to mybilly.com whitney spelled my b i
l l i e dot com slash whitney
it's been about 30 seconds since i
talked about my lover
and gotta bring it up because i know you
guys love the term lovers so
much i'm calling hr so he has student
loans he is a critical care veterinarian
and the more specialized you are in
critical care
he all he wants to do is save dogs lives
he saved my dog's life so sweet and
he is in debt most of his co-workers
that are as specialized as he is have
four hundred thousand dollars
in and student loan debt and they're
like 38
and all every check goes to their
student loans it
drives me insane anyway earnest.com
i still don't understand how these loans
work and how they are even
legal but you can use earnest to
refinance reduce your loan term you're
going to save money
combine multiple loans into a single
monthly payment so you're like wait
didn't i just pay that and
why are all these envelopes red oh
collections ernest is offering our
listeners a hundred dollar cash bonus
refinance your student debt at
earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply now
let's white this emily
what is that it's a little look a little
more chipper now ernest is giving our
listeners a hundred dollar bonus
refinance your student loans at
earnest.com whitney terms and conditions
apply
once again you get a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you visit earnest.com
whitney to refinance your student loan
not available in all states terms and
conditions apply just a question do
terms and conditions apply by any chance
i was going to make that joke too
get out of my brain visit earnest.com
whitney for more details
terms and conditions apply in case you
were wondering earnest student loan
refinancing made by earnest operations
llc nmls number one two
oh four nine one seven california
financing law
license number six oh five four seven
eight eight three
oh three second street sweep four one n
san francisco ca nine four 94107 venice
er
visit earnest.com licenses for a full
list of licenses
[Music]
oh my god i have so much to talk to you
about okay i want to ask you about
a is there was there ever like a bit you
were working on that you never
like quite figured out
like like i love talking about this
because i like i like trying to figure
out not that i do with many people
because i don't
care enough to but um but like a bit
you're like i can't tell if this isn't
working because people are too sensitive
or if it's like
not the time you know those bitches that
are like the one that got away
oh sure or something that was like this
joke is so funny but i
i like i think it orders there's
definitely there's definitely something
one that was like i mean like my comedy
also i feel like um
a comedian i really love is like
jacqueline novak who i'm very inspired
by
because uh she and she does this thing
where it's like you feel like she's
just going on a tangent or something but
it's like no this is actually like
written material so she did a um a show
called uh
get on your knees it was on broadway
kind of forever is there a place for
people to see that did they make us
no but i think they were going to make
it special and then covid
um so i hope i don't know just like as a
fan
yeah it could come it's about jobs no
one should be giving blow jobs at a
pandemic
i mean in this economy in fauci's
economy
so she because she yes she she is um a
very like
artistic speaker yeah every word is so
perfectly
chosen but it seems so conversational
right and and so she's just like a
master at that and so like i just i just
love
that vibe and i kind of had a bit that
was like about
me selling knives like when i was in
college
okay and it just video yeah we're kind
of nice
broke i sold coco for two summers so you
would call people
i would call people i would go to so the
bit is basically me being like it was so
i can't remember the intro joke or
whatever but there was some intro joke
about being like
people shouldn't trust my decision like
my even like i am young and stupid like
i sold knives for two summers in a row i
think like the
the tagline was them or like you know
the punch is like and i sold it for two
summers in a row or whatever
blah blah blah what was your pitch and
well it would just be like hey well also
the thing with cutco is like
you're calling the people in your damn
phone so it's so it's not like random
people it's like hey what's up my dad's
best friend
cecil like oh yeah i haven't seen you in
a while like
um like how's marsha doing you trying to
get some knives do you want to kill her
right and then you like go over and you
would do like a whole presentation
um so it's like girl scout cookies but
with knives yeah and then also you would
call people in your phone
like you went to high school with and be
like i know you're not doing nothing
so come here and sell that it is a
multi-level marketing scheme
i love multi-level marketing
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
okay i'm obsessed with mlm they're
incredible
i follow a lot of them on instagram yes
because
no words are real words no it's all
about elevating and expanding and
amplifying and your your customer base
like people talk about like personality
comedians like the mlm
is like the personality because it's
like scientology it's like
it's all about it's all about vibe it's
all about talking to you
for an hour and you have this no you
have no idea what the person just said
used until you end up buying like 20
sets of tupperware
or like six like crystal house like you
know
crystal chandeliers yeah or just like um
uh
ginkgo leaf powder pills
yes yes and i don't know if people just
buy it because they're like i just need
to get you stop talking to me so i'm
gonna buy this
or if it's like they make you feel like
you're dumb my mom was
involved in a lot of them when i was a
kid um
and i do think anna here we go on the
real there is probably something about
like
loneliness and community especially in
women
who maybe might have to be homemakers or
maybe might be
immigrants because you get to have the
tougher parties even though trying to
sell you
nothing ruins a friendship like trying
to sell your friends something that
doesn't work yes and then you become
your friend's boss
and tell them if they don't sell a
certain amount of the product that
you've gotten them roped into
they will be fired nothing better than
working for your friends
nothing less toxic than that you have to
get employees that you meet at the mall
at no point do they ever explain the
product you're selling no
and like my mom's friends were always
open here to mlm so then like i would
come home from school and then there
would be
like um you know like like six women my
mom met from the mall and half of them
don't speak english and they'd be like
in our living
room and they're selling yeah and
they're selling oils or lotions
or makeup or tupperware or crystal or
whatever
depending on the season and the chinese
lanterns and like we
feel weird about this yeah i mean the
good thing is there was there was
there was a lot of that stuff in my
house growing up never shortage of
plastic
never shortage of lotions or fake
vitamins but i
but then i sold knives and then i sold
the set to my parents and then i tried
to sell a set to my dad's best friend
and
poor cecil also what a sweet man he was
like you know this
is a scam right he was like so i i
i have heard of cuckoo knives before yes
i have io thank you very much
um i don't really know if we need one
right marge you know me
shaking me like blaze
i'm pretty obsessed i got into like a
very deep wormhole
about multi-level marketing yeah though
there were podcasts i was like
listening that's right i think wondering
did a really good yeah
yeah and where i was like i love this
and also you're working on this bit i'm
now totally
getting you well i was about to talk
about multi-level marketing excuse even
more of loving mlm
i'm trying to google the woman that um
because they do say like and in my life
i make a million dollars a year
a million dollars and they are sitting
in an office that does look represents
that
on a sitcom like that would be like
the hotel room set on a sitcom
like gold like curtains with like
emblazoned
floral like lots of like like drapery
water
paperweights paper you the paper weights
that's like um like a
heavy sea shell yes wait paperweight and
then there's like lots of plants
seriously made of like glass somehow
there it's always like um i'm what is
the
pier one it's a lot of like the most
expensive thing
i got here one important this was like
pure it's an actual
pier one like she said
it's like the exact candles it's kind of
like borderline christmas decorations
it's all like silver and blue and all
the women look the exact same age
exact same like face and exact same like
extensions and the whole thing
big cloths we're talking yeah and like a
boat neck black top and they're
so happy i i also got into this rabbit
hole of like because i
i grew up um christian and so i'm always
interested in like
christianity in this country especially
like evangelical christians and there's
a very interesting like
evangelical mlm overlap
especially like i think when it comes to
like the oils
and the tinctures because it's like i
don't know
then there's religious stuff that i
can't really expect you know that made
the thing about it that i mean
because all the so what we do it's all
about like you know i think that we're
this is kind of changing a little bit
with like podcasts and like more and
more like people being able to like
you know yes but the idea of like come
on
like there's a certain group of
communities that want to help other
comedians
now do you know what i mean it's a lot
about like let's share like oh let me
like give up my spot and like
like you come on my show it helps you
like yeah we figured
we figured out that collaborating helps
everybody yeah
so it's not necessarily benevolent it
might actually just be
mercenary but it is what it is it is
what it is
but in multi-level marketing they all
seem so dedicated to helping you grow
your business
which is always so sketchy to me like
real business people would be like
wouldn't tell you all their tricks right
well that's i mean and that's like the
the reality is that that's
not happening that's the framework
to help them grow their business
and like to help because they're like
buy my book about how to grow your
business
sneaky and and like also you know in
terms of percentages it's like
i want to help you grow your business
you should rope in free people to doing
this
percentage from those people but for you
to start okay yeah
if i help you grow your business i get
paid what a that's just a coincidence
that's random as well i feel like those
people should probably get employees too
oh my god employee if you grow your
business i get richer
so that's it's mercenary uh selfishness
yeah okay yeah yeah oh fascinating
mercenary selfish
name of my next special okay so you were
telling the stroke and it kind of hit
or did it would either hit or miss yeah
and i think that
just because like i would go on this
sort of like
this sort of articulated ramble
of like the ups and downs of selling
knives and then being involved and
cecil himself and um either at the end
of it it would just be like
woohoo or just like are you okay though
but can we circle back to your mental
health we need to actually
actually just leave stick the pin in
that and leave it there there are
certain things and because i like i'm
curious to ask you these because i do
feel like a lot of jokes that are like
hit or miss on stage or like
really hinge on your energy level that's
a great story for a podcast yeah yeah
yeah
for sure right so it's like all my like
failed bits i'm like that's probably a
podcast story ultimately this podcast
wasn't around really when i was started
telling it
right that's what that was my logic yeah
but that's really interesting to me like
the line of
the audience going with you on a dark
journey but i'm not feeling sorry for
you or worrying about you
yeah i think also kind of recently
towards but towards
pandemic uh starting there were a lot of
cause i just got to this place where i
was like i don't want to talk about
um like race on stage or like
my gender like explicitly on stage but
like if this happens to be a part of the
story and the joke
then great yeah like let's include it
but i didn't want to talk about these
things explicitly so i was just like
trying a bunch of new stuff
and i think also because of that it was
like very hit or miss yeah yeah yeah i
had a
section i was working on that i don't
even really remember i remember it was
like
period jokes and it would be like
but it was like it would be like every
other joke would be like this is a hit
and this is a mess and i
and i i don't know i just was like i
want to tell like jokes about my fucking
period because i feel like there's like
build my house okay go that direction as
hard as you can
i'm trying to get land
for myself i want that for my for my
progeny do you feel like because i do
feel like there's this this
this i'm i'm really into feminists that
are secretly bullies
um or self-proclaimed feminists that are
like you i'm a feminist but you have to
do everything
my way you're not underwear makeup
you're not allowed to
like flowers you're not like i was in
some it least not even a show that i was
like
working on i was just trying to like
help something and they're like okay
it's about like four
badass women like once a lawyer one's a
ceo
one's a neurosurgeon and one is like a
spy and i'm like
why do powerful women only have to like
be the
powerful men what they chose can one
like be a florist if that's what
she want or an interior design like if
that's what she wants to do
to me it's like your level of success
success is a whatever the word feminist
has gotten so like toxic i feel like but
it's just if you set a goal and are able
to achieve it and then there's no
bullshit in the way of you
doing what you want to do like just
because yeah if you're a successful
interior designer you're not like a
sellout because you do something kind of
domestic or that's traditionally been
deemed domestic
right right that like if that's your
life if that's your choice and like go
the fuck
i feel like there's this thing now where
women feel like in order to be strong
women or like
they just have to be like founders of
billion dollar companies like that's not
the only
yes option i mean it's like i know girls
were growing up and it's like she's a
stay-at-home mom now and she's a fucking
boss in that and that's literally what
she wants to do
i remember in high school she was like i
don't want to fucking work i feel like
there's so much i look at your
generation
i feel so bad for them because they're
just like oh god i guess i gotta
go like build a company now i gotta
go be like like found an app it
definitely is wild to feel like a place
where it's like oh so
everybody's paved um a path for me and
now i have to forge
and then on that for sure yeah it seems
so sad to me that's like i guess i have
to like
like be the founder of a female
workspace now
it's like you also can just do what you
want to do
and that's fine too and that's like
revolutionary in its own way i feel like
and i i do wonder how much of it is true
that i'm like
oh this is changing societally and how
much of my feeling is like
no i think i just am getting a little
bit older and i'm gaining more
experience and also more exhaustion
and so i actually want to mellow out my
life a little more and like that's okay
too but i do think i was watching um
fleabag the other day the first i was
like re-watching the first season
because i was like i just want to see
how this
still hits if it still hits the same way
and it was so interesting to kind of
like remember i also did a girls
re-watch
and it's very interesting to remember
that like
earlier the show girl yes yes yes um
just watching the girls
um now it should be called gals okay um
it was like interesting to kind of
remember like the ways that
we talked about like feminism and like
the way that that
then um trickled down into how that was
perceived and like art and it's like you
didn't realize things were actually
being like
sort of um i don't know
put in these buzzwords it'd be like very
like girl boss and like yes queen and
like yeah
which by the way a bunch of men made
money off selling those shirts
i'm sorry like i'm sorry i am so you
feel free to argue with me about this
stuff but when everyone's like let's do
like a female james bond where like
james bond is a woman it's jane bond i'm
like you realize if you fucking do that
you're just giving the guy that wrote
the original movie more money the guy
that wrote the song
is making more money and this movie's
gonna fucking bomb
and you know it and people go see that's
why women shouldn't be like superheroes
right
some movies it's like there's other
stories to tell that are like original
but they're also like okay let's make
women
scumbags too and be like it's just like
what is this
what are we doing a woman being a spy
i'm gonna be sexist like
every woman is a james bond already yeah
but it is
it i don't know it's like even when i
think there's like companies where it's
like
you know oh this this is actually run by
like shitty women what do you mean wait
a minute and it's like
well yeah i mean it's like you know they
found out that if you like attached like
we had a good blessed run through the
company yes queen or whatever
like to the face and to the title don't
call him a queen too
soon we can't give
people too much self-esteem it doesn't
go well this new thing of like
everybody is like like the you're the
best you're perfect it's like no you're
not
let's just you it's something i have a
lot of anxiety about also i feel like
being kind of younger and
like not be like i'm anything or
whatever there's like a ways to go
but like being younger and knowing that
there's eyes on me or whatever i'm like
i'm like i want to get in front and say
that this is a work in progress i would
like to be the first to say
that uh there is more to do because
there's a thing that's like oh you're
famous and you have followers
but you're you're not allowed to have
that unless you're a perfect human being
that's never made any mistakes there's
like
since when like it's also it's like it's
it's who set the precedent
that an artist who self-deprecates and
talks publicly about their mistakes and
advertises their deepest darkest secrets
and
grossest impulses are now supposed to be
like a moral compassion
yeah like no no we're perverts but this
is perverted to
do we are because i just i don't think
it's fair that someone has to like
be brilliant like you make shows like be
on shows and you also have to be like
the moral compass and someone's hero
yeah i it is an interesting like
spotlight and also i feel like there
have been like
um requests sometimes where like a you
know college student is like hey do you
want to like talk to my class and i'm
like i do because i remember what's the
pay
being your age and not knowing anything
and nobody would help or or if they did
help you know
you know it's like a small white guy who
looks like a chest not in
glasses being like you fucking kids
don't know
fucking anything and you're all idiots
and you'll never make it and
anyways i uh wrote a script i shed it
out and
18 people butt it and you're like okay
what like help me though
but like how do i get the union yeah
just like how do i get representation
get like can anybody answer a legitimate
question for me comedians that i looked
up to i was watching them on roasts i
was watching them
on uh uh vh1 shows
oh like those um the best week ever
soup and i love the talk soup yeah
and like and all the like i love the 80s
and 90s and where i was like not only am
i learning about culture but like i
didn't even realize
i was like looking at comedians who i
would then be like oh
i'm watching comedy central wait a
minute there's like a half hour by this
person oh this random person oh patricia
looking random
um you know and then it's like wait a
minute like i this is how i was like
studying and learning but like
that sort of exercise and getting to
just like
do jokes and and and like get exposure
and like and i'm sure like make
connections in a certain way too
is like kind of gone
interesting because yeah that's my main
thing is when everyone's like how did
you do it i'm like the way i did it
doesn't exist that path
doesn't exist anymore so i don't want to
mislead you like and say
do this this is this my thing is always
like work harder than anybody
and um you can never be seen too late
right you know
even where i'm like oh yeah like i was
just like doing a bunch of shows in
brooklyn and then i would have people on
my shows
and they would have me on their shows
and it's like oh right there's no shows
really right
now because everybody's inside the house
no one wants to hear it because it's
always like if i was
20 and just starting i would fucking
hate someone that told me this even
though it's true it's just
you just have to be the funniest yeah
you just have to be on stage
every single every single day eating
every single day
until one day you wake up and you're
like damn i'm on my fucking shit also
you have to love bombing
you have to love it if you if you can't
don't like bombing and you only have a
good time when you kill like it's just
not for you
maybe be a lawyer maybe be like the
funniest dentist maybe like i don't know
be a writer like i don't know what to
tell you like you have this it's such a
specific thing yeah my thing is if
you're asking it might not even be
for you because if you want to be a
stand-up there's no one can tell you
shit there's just like you just go for
it i feel like and it is like
i don't know it's like you have i had
this addiction this compulsion
like an addiction yeah go up and bomb
and be so mad at myself and it's like
well i guess i'm doing it again too much
but i'll fix it tomorrow let's see what
it's literally like fixing what the fuck
is
speed dating like you don't go on a date
drunk and you feel like shit the next
day you're like oh my god like
he saw me drunk if he only knew what i
really was like and knew how charming i
was and now i'm gonna go on another date
i'm having one cheering to take the edge
off like it is like no that actually is
your personality it isn't
just who i am i don't know who you are i
would say like the the only thing i can
really say to anyone is like
no one should understand what you're
doing and no one should really approve
too much and no one
should get it i always i'm very afraid i
have like that like universal acclaim
you know whenever there's something it's
like everybody loves
nope not good and not just like okay
okay yeah yeah
you might be the universally beloved
person that makes it
but like who me yeah but you have some
haters in here yes that's good
dm about my teeth yeah yeah good good
good that's a good sign
that's good i need them i need them or
in the opposite corner i guess i want to
have a point of view
and i want to make sure that people like
know that like i do have a point of view
and i just do have things
to say and it's like i am doing my thing
that only i can do
yes yes as well where it's like i think
it's interesting for me where i don't
know i could like feel myself like
crafting my voice and like as i do it
more like getting closer to my voice and
that was also something that was like
so frustrating about the pandemic
hitting and being like okay i guess i'm
doing zoom shows yeah that's such a
bummer eight months but where i was in
this place where i was like damn i
really
am like going up like every night and
either i'm like
crushing or i'm eating shit but it's
like i'm worried i don't know what's
right i just don't know what the fuck is
happening but it's like i could
feel myself getting closer to like what
are the things that
i want to do or wait a minute i thought
i didn't like
doing like period material well like i
was like if i can hate this shit and
then i'm like
let's fucking see what i care about
it's also like when people say like oh
my god female comics talking about sex
and periods and whatever it's like
i did that a lot but the people that
heard it
i mean the special i talked about it and
i don't even know where to find it
so it's like a lot of shit we shot like
the networks are gone
you know so it's like the next
generation has to talk about it through
their perspective so the shit the
the complaints i made about birth
control and period and sex and stuff
like that is
it's changed and it's like it's like i i
hate watching this like
younger generation of comics be like
scared to talk about things because
they've been talked about before
the reality is your take on it is going
to be so different that's like
it doesn't matter yeah right and also
it's like
not like our take as a generation but
also you have to hope like
your take as an individual like that so
you guys just put it in like
your hand now and bury it or something
what do you guys do with your periods
go up and then on your tampons aren't
full of perfume anymore
[Laughter]
aren't you well it's in my day
when we watched period commercials the
the
fluid on it was neon blue yeah and now
it's like in a commercial it's like a
woman free bleeding and she's staring
directly in the game
and i can do this wherever i want even
in the workplace
this is the abortion i just had
it's okay and it's biodegradable bitch
and it's in the shape of bernie sanders
so it's like it's like you have vagina
like like what are the things like are
there things that your generation thinks
are like
hacky to talk about like in my day it
was like like airplane food like
homeless people i come and be like oh
that's so fucking unoriginal like i've
heard
like do you ever come in and you're like
oh that's like off limits to talk about
because i've heard
like other comics have talked about it i
think there are things where it's
like um stuff about like hipsters
and like about like oh these like
sensitive bleeding heart young people oh
all they do is crying
fucking
have you heard a 24 year old uh complain
that they're traumatized by lyme disease
have you heard what white 25 year olds
think this will say that it's really
triggering just
um you know my head explodes i'm
bleeding out of my eyes
as long as it's period by the time i'm
on my cycle
sync up this cause there are some things
that i'm like i feel like everyone
and i'm generalizing obviously that is
my job
for a living like it's never gonna be
right but
so many of the people i specifically in
my experience
um that young people like i'm they're so
excited to like take
be bosses and take over the world and
all this stuff and it's like but you're
like feel unsafe around like because of
uh
like i don't know a book that like john
wayne like why are we even spending time
on him you know
yeah like i do wonder even though
sometimes i like have this thing where
i'm like
i actually don't think that's young
people like i actually am like that's
actually people
who are to me older people and they're
like i don't know how it got to
be put on us but like i'm not canceling
john wayne i don't know who that is
i don't know what that is this i don't
have black and white tv
my shit's in 4k the fuck are you talking
about i'm watching a damn marvel movie
who is that i
once tweeted something about like i was
watching like a black panther the reason
all these racist touches haven't been
taken out there's no no
when like stuff was coming out about you
know it's like oh this tv show is now
canceled and they're removing episodes i
remember texting my friends i was like
wait i thought the episode was funny am
i wrong to me
taking it down is like admitting you
were racist
with your intentions at the time i love
the thing that like disney did i think
where they were like
hey so um we're gonna leave this up
because it's a classic
this represents views from a certain
period of time right which one
over what i think they did it for like a
bunch of stuff but like pocahontas where
the white man just
loved the indian women and had
consensual sex with them that was like
kind of my life so
i i can't really speak on that boy
like how dare you that's my romeo and
juliet story
but um like i don't know where they were
like you know
shit's changed obviously not they were
like stop strange
but um you know that represents views
that people
had and now times are changing and that
is a good
thing yeah this is what it was it was i
think people are going to look at us
using microwaves the same way
yeah i just bought a new microwave after
not using one for eight years i was like
fucked up
that's really impressive yeah yeah i
almost didn't buy a microwave for my new
apartment and then i was like
um but there's that's kind of the damage
i went through emily remembers this i
went through like a whole thing where i
got every piece of radiation around my
house but here's what it is it's
more that like it becomes when we start
to focus on like one thing like no
microwave in my house like that i don't
get like whatever the emf said it
then you get into like well what about
my phone but i also live near this gas
station but i'm also near this phone
line i'm also flying on planes i'm also
breathing l.a air
i feel like it's like when people are
like oh like um
the government can see me through my
computer and it's like babe you have a
phone
on you and you
speaking of a joke that doesn't really
hit consistently
i well here's the thing i feel like when
i go into offices now everyone has like
their
table camera and like i'm always like no
offense but who do you think you are
all you're doing is telling your
co-workers you can't stop jerking off
like that's
all we think who do you think like
to me i'm all this is not a joke that i
do it's like to me
like i love that you think the
government's so organized right if they
need to find
that fire yeah like what they can't they
can hardly fucking function as a
government the idea that it's like yes i
have that uh
that conversation he had from four years
ago like they don't have you been in the
dmv like
they're still using paper and like file
it's it's it's it's there's
yeah it's a mess yeah if they're
recording it there's another priority
no one can pull it up if they are
recording is by accident yes
they're supposed to be recording a
terrorist but they're just recording
comedians in a writer's room
they're recording a 37 year old like uh
you know
dental hygienist from topeka
that the idea that is supposed to be
recording criminals
but they're just like dvr'ing csi
there's like wait a second
fuck we should be more specific with the
intern
like i just that this is the thing let
me go to the bureaucracy and the
disorganization
it's always been like that why do we
expect anything different i think that's
my thing is that like everything
that is a hassle today has always been a
hassle on a different iteration like
everything we complain about and
besides racism and sexism and like like
rape and it's like
you can get me on that disclaimer i'm
just like
you know if you know who i am by now you
know who i am yes like you fuck with me
or you don't and you like people know
that i like
say like broad shit to try to get a more
specific point which is like
you know when people are like i can't
believe people take photos of their kids
they're showing
photos of their kids to strangers this
is horrible like people i hear mom's
complaining about other moms
on social media and i was working on
this joke about like parents have always
done that they just used to do it like
with their wallets
you know like it's always been of
everything that's like
bad today my dad pervert had me front
facing his desk everybody could see
me bring us to work in my car again
they had take your daughters to work
where they would parade us around
i'm gonna cancel my idea like there's
always
have done they've always done a version
of this right showing me to
other floors
[Laughter]
periods parading you around
and then she dresses up like a janitor
what do you think was gonna happen
there's always been like some version of
of what everyone's complaining about
nightlife i look at like
young people in their 20s and i'm like i
want so badly for you guys to like enjoy
your 20s yeah and maybe that's just i do
think the majority of people
are though i do think it's like this
thing where it's just like you know
you can find whatever you want online
yes for whatever online and especially
i think sometimes the most wrong people
are the loudest people
yeah and it's like if you go people who
are
miserable and young and not it's like
yeah you're gonna you can find that
right if you look for it but like i do
think to that point where
i don't know like earlier it's like the
canceling and stuff it's like none of my
friends aren't doing that right now
it's awesome the people that are afraid
of being canceled are the ones that are
amplifying it like i have this whole
theory that like
cancel culture is being perpetrated by
comedians who are afraid of being
cancelled
like it's like it's all any comedian
talks about there was like five tweets
about it and was like
shit what we want because comedians are
deeply sensitive
melodramatic deeply feeling and it just
comes out probably legitimate victims at
some point so they're just recreating
their childhood circumstances and it's
sort of like
do you need to say tranny you weren't
saying tranny before why do you need to
fight to say it
you've never had a joke about it like
why
well then they have the freedom to say
their side right how do you not see the
irony in this
yeah yeah it is the communities that
complain the most about cancer culture
i'm like you have you're literally your
entire act
right it's like about your wife and like
it's it's not edgy at all right but it's
also the people who i feel like
like i don't know were people who i was
like you were so
edgy you were you were um
counter culture like you were saying the
crate like the you know exciting thing
or whatever that
people weren't saying for and so now
somebody is
bringing a new opinion to you yeah and
you're like hold up hold up hold up yeah
no no no you're not gonna infringe on my
beliefs yeah it's like wait what just
listen
yeah and if you're cool and really do
have something to say
then it's like it won't be i don't know
my belief like it won't change your life
so much
my whole thing is remember um you're
like like
evolving and being like i love the idea
of like oh that's wrong like oh cool
what's the new thing
like whatever happened to wanting to be
cool right right so you learn the new
thing
right so that you're not dumb people
like i want to stay dumb
you know it's like of course things are
going to change not like everything
evolves like
you don't go to the the fucking doctor
and when they give you the little
temperature gun you're like no i want
the thermometer in my butt
oh my god that's what i've i've always
done and that's the way it should be
done forever it's like there's when
there's no
do it rectal and you're sucking the
boogers out my nose by the way
and you're gonna use that little hammer
on my knee because that was science
like what like it's still my blood with
leeches bitch that's the only way i'm
doing it's like
since when do we hate progress so much
right like the same person's like we
can't say
tranny anymore it's also like where i
buy that like hoverboard
so that i can like get to san francisco
from la in 24 seconds like fly
it's like it's just a weird thing to be
stuck on i guess
you know and i think people get off on
and to me when i look
at the like consistently if i'm going to
like generalize it's usually the people
that don't have real problems that just
like want to feel like a victim
yes and want to like make a problem so
that they can be they can be a victim
it's like oh you can't say training and
that's the hardest part of your day like
congratulations you're the safest and
happiest person on the planet
right and it's also like you know are
like young people and like
like colleges or whatever like sensitive
or are you also just like
older and you know there's like cell
phones now so like your joke about a
landline ain't hitting the same
yeah yeah yeah like times have changed
like you
you have gotten older look back at a
picture from 10 years ago
you you cringe at the bangs you cringe
at the haircut you had 10 years ago like
why don't you look back and go oh i
can't believe i made that joke 10 years
ago right like you're allowed to have
been wrong
but i think taking off the okay it's not
your
but i also it's not your fault like
times have
just changed unless it is your fault and
you're an active race yeah
yeah yeah and you've and you've done
harm right then okay
wait a minute hold on wait say sorry
real quick and then
just change the i i really remember
feeling this way like during the summer
where like i had people
i mean people from the woodwork were
coming out and being like
how do i talk to my family and i was
like i don't
know i don't even i don't even know you
talk to your family that's your first
mistake
like you know but it's like that's what
you got to deal with in your own
family like i'm not going to come out to
connecticut and like have a sit down
dinner with your dad
and yeah yeah break down systemic racism
for him also like i don't what the fuck
would i say
yeah yeah like i got my own shit to deal
with yeah that's not your job that's not
yeah you know there's plenty of books
out there when everybody oh god well we
just talked about
this google which is like and well
google i but it'll speak
you'll be a little discerning
yes like there's plenty of people that
are we uh brandon government was on last
week and it's like
here there's there's enough information
out there that you have no excuse to not
know
right like it's on you what's going on
with you that you don't know by now let
me ask you this now makes me i want to
know like where do you get your news
like what like as someone your age well
that
i mean a bad real answer is like twitter
um that's the tragic real answer that
shouldn't be
that because you're able to follow the
sites that you trust
right which is what i mean also i think
i can't i get anything where i can
um both see the news and then see
opinions
and then kind of like decide my opinion
in the middle of seeing those
opinions which i think is like an
interesting
you know phenomena or whatever to like
not only see a piece of news but see
somebody be like
that's really cool and then c7 people be
like that's really stupid
and then op-ed and news into one
yeah and i feel like my brain
and i i don't know if that's this is
just because of like kind of
coming of age like as you know twitter
was like blowing up and stuff
if like my brain kind of filters things
do you think people should be
platformed interesting
like do you mean like if they're if it
just like
does everybody yeah the internet needs
to be
just unplugged from the ocean do you
think you should be de-platform so
you're not spending so much time on
there
i love you i love to personally be deep
platform so i can like talk call my
mother
you need to tweet some offensive shit
just so it doesn't kick you off it's the
only way out
i have friends who've done that yeah
they've like impersonated like that's
why you like impersonate a public figure
and you're verified
so that you get reported so that you
like aren't addicted to twitter that is
so funny to me because i used to
when i was broke when i was 21 i used to
sign head shots of other famous people
and sell them
that's so so i used to impersonate above
my finger
but like with headshots that's
incredible that's really a perfect
thank you scam thank you you could scam
back in the day there were no there was
no trail
yeah damn the glory days really i
missed man i really i got in with my
knives and i got out now if you steal
something from somebody they can just
look on ebay and be like why did you
take my shit and sell it no and then
they'll make a tick tock that's like so
this bitch stole from me and by the way
she works at the fucking
market basket off of um
i like those tick tocks i like being
able to hold celebrities accountable for
their shitty behavior but when someone's
like nicki minaj didn't tip at this
restaurant i'm like
did she even know i'm so afraid of like
i'll just
whatever like do moi that type of like
stuff yeah
oh god duma is the feed that has done
next to my house and um also he was
wearing this and um
by the way um he was actually shorter
than i thought he was so um
and also i followed him home and like i
feel like you're the asshole in this
scenario
but i moved him home to his house and
you said please stop following me um
what a fucking
dick but there are some that are that
are like
going after people that are very much
glorified for being like
girls girls and like like super like
anti-racist
and they're like uh this is what
happened but that's what i mean what i
was saying earlier where it's like
people don't cancel people i think
unless they're like they're kind of like
annoyed or they're like
a little too late maybe straight up aziz
if you want to hire me for the next
season of your show
i'll be there but people
were he like we'll talk about
neurodivergence i i don't i can't speak
for that but
i don't know but he was so rude to
everyone for so long
that they were like felt like slighted
by him and i don't know if he was
choosing to be rude or if he was just
busy because i'm the kind of person that
was like when someone's like
i'm sure a lot of people think i'm a
bitch because i was just busy and
insecure and scared
so before i go on stage sometimes people
were like i never thought i could talk
to you i thought you were such a bitch
and i was like no i was just so insecure
because i was trying to get your
approval
in my notes and i went on stage and i
got in my car and cried real fast
it's a different story than what you
projected right so maybe that's the case
i do feel like i mean it's kind of
interesting to think of like people
who maybe they were rude or maybe they
maybe they were having a bad day
whatever but then people are like all
right if your downfall comes i won't be
praying for it but i won't be
i will be helping you either just sort
of think they just didn't
whereas like chris hardwick every one of
his ex has stepped in and ever
all his friends were like nope because
he was always so kind to everybody and
they were like this is like wrong
whereas other people when someone was
rude to them because we're
such narcissists we're like yeah i could
see him doing that i could totally see
him
imagine that yeah he got too many
specials too soon i can totally imagine
him doing that
you know it's interest it's an
interesting i don't know it's like it's
really a
yeah i feel like that's been my whole um
approach as of late where i just kind of
like
i wasn't there so we'll see how it
shakes out like
i'm not impressed by any of this like
i believe her and they'll hear it and
the only data i have is this
right i'm just catching the news as i
catch it like um whoever was right i
wish them the best of luck
i'm not a jury i can't tweet about this
right i don't know enough information
it's been shut in my mouth a lot lately
it's very nice it's very close i have
not been
i've got about three group chests that
are the ones that i'm firing off my shit
in
that's where i say my bullshit you have
i have a couple group chats that if they
were ever to be
seen ruined i would truly
finished be over i talk shit about my
mother in those things
shit i don't even mean finished there's
stuff
i mean there was i've had to actively
like stop like there's been a couple
people
and i must be jealous of them or i must
be
and i deeply admire them all i have a
couple chains where all we do is screen
grab other people's instagram and like
clown on them
and i'm like do i love am i obsessed
with that i think i want to be this
birds do i want to be this person yeah
probably and
yeah you are because it's more painful
to to know that about yourself
i think the thing that i do is where i'm
like oh late i'm seeing behavior that i
actually recognize oh my
god this could be me after two drinks i
gotta watch it
that's how i would be if i wasn't um
so conscious of myself like if i was
like free
if i was truly free this is actually how
it would be that the people i hate the
most are
like if i was fucking this much more
secure with myself
that's what i wanted yeah that's how i
would behave if i fucking like myself
fuck you yeah and instead there's like
this veneer of like
oh i'm self-aware no bitch i'm like
i'm just aware no you're not like you're
crying in your bathtub and just actually
the opposite i actually refuse to know
myself yeah the harder thing is like i
feel like there's a little bit of
a conflating of like i'm authentic
i'm self-aware with like i
am um committed to having this like what
we call a 12-step program like defective
character
or flaw and then you would attach to
that thing and then it becomes your
identity
and then you have to you have to make a
phone call
fucking some sort of something like
immediately
i'm just saying don't get so attached to
the things that get you attention
in terms of like all of these like flaws
and weakness not everybody needs to know
everything first of all like
some of the best self-care you can do is
restrain a pen and tongue like you don't
just write these giant essays about how
insecure you are and how socially
awkward you are because you're not
cooked yet first of all
and you don't want to put something in
writing that then you're gonna have to
be loyal to for the rest of your life
and then people come up to you i wrote a
book about eating disorders and
assault and all this and migraines and
i'm really glad that i did a migraine to
come from something really
and um and abuse and alcoholism and
addiction it's like i'm really glad i
got all that out and i'm really glad i
shared it in a book and not on the
internet as much
people still come up to me and they're
like i have an eating disorder and i'm
going through this thing and you save my
life and i'm like
huh like i don't even remember that
person
and then i have to re-traumatize myself
not that that's part of being of service
that's part of what i do but there's
also like
a version of like of like i am feeling
all these things
not everyone needs to know all this
about me so that i'm making a positive
contribution
i was just talking about this today in
one of those group chats where
i i i was like it's so interesting like
i feel like
as young people as well it's like we've
had this ability
to share those things and i think also
like i don't know for myself it's like
when i first started my instagram it was
posting pictures of like you know my
parents and doing cat you know whatever
it's like nobody knew who the fuck i was
yeah so
there was this element of like this is
for my friends it's for you know me or
whatever
and then some over time it's like that
changes
and your own also like i feel like i'm
not type of person who's like oh
people i'm fucking popping up you know i
still want to be myself so
i still i would share things so you
don't have any as long as you're doing
it because you want to but as long as
you don't feel you
owe it yeah because there's been a part
of me where it's like damn maybe i just
won't do another interview
until i turn 39. no that's
because when you put yourself out this
is the trap of being up like public and
everyone if you have a hundred followers
you're probably it's gonna
it's all about ratios you know it's not
but that's also a thing where i think
about that a lot where it's like
everybody
is a public figure now 100 that is that
so anything that we're saying on this
podcast is applicable
whether you live in like pensacola and
have 10 followers because it feels
like you know it's the same thing so
it's like cause somebody in in
in fucking tampa can find your shit and
be like ooh this bitch in pensacola
popping
yeah yeah but it's also it's the same
thing with like when uh when a
celebrity's like oh my god but
uh uh my heartbreak was so much worse
because like the guy was dating was
famous so i like saw him everywhere like
if you live in toledo ohio
you're gonna be you're dude at the
but like it's also with um so for me
like all the animal rescue stuff i do
stuff like that it's like
i everyone's gonna be mad at me all the
time is sort of like my thing and you
have to get okay with that because then
if i have like
a vintage purse from the 50s that i
bought because i'm trying not to engage
in fast fashion
and i'm trying not to buy new overpriced
bullshit that's gonna like like
like i'm really big on like financial
abuse and the way that we
what what oh no i heard i heard i heard
that's
part of the sentence wrong like i heard
it first i probably got a really big
advocate for financial abuse
i'm such an advocate i don't pay anybody
here it's all like
fake bitcoin um i'm like you have a
stake in this stock but i also think
that like
like i think that i just want younger
people to know that they don't
have they're not obligated to share
everything with everyone all the time
they're not
obligated to be fucked up i feel like
though it's like you know i don't know i
think
you learn things as you get older and i
also wonder i mean like
shout out eighth grade but where i'm
like i wonder this is kind of like my
generation and the generation after like
that's kind of like our pain
and like that's how that's how we're
going to learn he is kind of like
doing too much and no i'm going to help
you
[Music]
let me let me love you non-consensually
like i just i'm like i want to say like
i i just wouldn't be like i'm authentic
and i do this and benson i fight about
all the time because i'm like
at work you shouldn't necessarily be
authentic you don't have to tell
everyone everything you don't have to
tell your boss what you're going through
like
keep something secret right right so
that you
authentic to like have things for
yourself yes and to have things for
the people in your life that are not for
everybody else so it's cool to have a
hobby that nobody knows about i wish we
lived in a world where nobody held
anything against you but that's just not
the case what i'm saying is if you're
pregnant don't tell your boss um but
i'm just saying there's certain people
that it's certain things it's not about
like i have to hide or be unauthentic
it's just
it's none of your business so a lot of
things are your business and you don't
have to share it all because then
whether you like it or not people are
going to hold it against you down the
line
or you're not going to be able to evolve
and grow because those people are still
going to ask you questions about it so
like
i went through this like horrible
breakup uh like when i was 30 told
everyone everything you know
and then no one would set me up with a
good guy because they're like well she's
too crazy she'll never like a good guy
like i set myself up for future failure
and that's real that is real i was
trying to get over it and then for the
next year everyone's like so how's it
going with the thing and i'm like i
don't have to talk about it again
because i talked about it i talked about
it because i can't stop talking about it
and so now everybody thinks that's all i
talk about
yes and then the amount of energy we
like to please and then we write a story
about ourselves that we feel like we've
we have to contin my thing is like i
want to be able to
i would like to reserve the right to be
a completely different person tomorrow
but if i told everybody this is who i am
i'm like i can't change
if you just start living like that then
it will happen like that's kind of how
i'm trying to live yeah it's like i
actually can be
i could be a different person tomorrow
if i choose to and if anybody wants to
hold that against me
then they're wasting their time because
it's too late because sometimes like i
have people come up to me
and they're like oh my god my lips a
nightmare and i have this and this and
this and you're
you inspire me i'm like well i'm good
now i got over it i worked on it and i
fixed myself
i'm so sorry i'm just sorry no
like this is the new me i'm glad i did
it because i think that there's a time
and a place for it
but there's also but also it's like if i
choose to revisit this in a different
way
yes then that's my prerogative and i
might be okay
i wasn't yesterday but today i am and i
don't need you to cast me in a role
where i'm like sick forever
so that i feel like i have to keep
showing up as this person
for you for you that's some of the
hardest shit for like artists to be able
to evolve because your fans get so
attached to the person they know
and then you show up like i'll do i was
doing all these sets about like how
you know fucked up i was my stand-up
specials and now i'm like life is great
i'm good
everyone's like what right like i
thought you were the mess
you were making us feel better about
ourselves and i'm like no now in my shit
together and i was like
you know whatever you know so for me i
think it's like a delicate balance and i
feel like i
over shared i mean i went at howard
sternum like cry
like it was like i'm glad i think at the
time it was important to do
yeah because no one was really like
doing that but um
but there's now i'm at a place where i'm
like no i'm not gonna
talk about my personal relationship so
much to where i
scare him away and everyone's like oh is
that fucking
yeah that was a messy bitch yeah they
got a bitch an orgasm guy hey
like i don't need to because i didn't
even know that
now when people listen to us they like
remember what we say
that is i i um a friend sent me
my wikipedia the other day
and it was like there were things there
were sentences like cross-referenced
with
tweets like things that they had gleaned
from tweets and
like you know um figured out my birthday
based on a tweet i did when i was like
and then like figured out what my
parents did based on like a podcast
you know appearance and like those were
all like the links and i was like we
gotta maybe get some of that stuff scrub
or i have to shut up
here's my deal enough about me more
about my deal
i am to me the phone is just a dangerous
place
i text exes i respond to emails i have
no business responding to i get
adrenalized
so for me i'm always looking for things
to
engage me i have such a short attention
span i don't know if you noticed
and uh the best fiends which we've
talked about in this podcast for a while
benton was like super super into it he
got me hooked on it
and it's just such a like fun diversion
from like emails and news and all this
stuff that just like stresses me out and
i was just touring for the past couple
weekends and i was playing best fiends
in the airport
flew by see had such a nice experience
something new every day
it was just such a fun and little things
are you know that i'm stuck with little
cuties
the little snails with the eyeballs like
they're so positive and they're so fun
if you're hungry for a near endless
supply of fun puzzles the kind you could
actually enjoy solving try out best
fiends script your brain
download the five star rated puzzle game
best fiends free today on the app store
or google play that's friends without
the r
you know i love bees you know i love
obsessed with bees look at you look at
the beach
i know be with one two hold on one tooth
and one giant eyeball it's just so
cute i want babies continue no work
that's
that's all the information read the rest
that's it girl i'm telling you
download the five star puzzle game yep
you said that yes i did oh well i was
busy playing best fiend see
it's a great way to just tune out people
that annoy you you want to talk about
pork rinds or what
so i was with my stylisto yesterday
uh doing a photo shoot for i'm bilingual
now um a photo shoot for the next
tour and she i had these piglets pork
rinds
they are so good outstanding foods
obsessed with you
she has two pigs that live with her and
she was like i've been meaning to find
them like where did you find that
like she's obsessed with them um and she
hadn't even tried them then i gave them
to her and i was like oh your mind is
about to be blown
and it was blown it's still all over the
wall we have to repaint
it's the first snack ever that you can
also have as a meal music to my ears i
mean it's just one thing that's it
that's it each bag has 21 grams of
protein and the nutrients of a
multivitamin including iron calcium
vitamins b12 d and e and they come in
four delicious flavors look at emily's
hair it's thicker than it's ever been it
oh not scientifically proven okay but we
know what we're saying here
we can have opinions about
adults about this so these are
plant-based snacks they were created by
chef dave anderson who led r d up and
beyond meat and created the beyond
burger
a lot of people don't understand that
every not everything a lot of the things
that they're eating that they think are
healthy
gluten they have gmos artificial
ingredients trans fats correct
cholesterol
and soy which now we're learning
soy's not what the the magical uh bean
we thought
panacea it's not the magical bean
soybean
what's it mean we've worked out an
exclusive deal for good for you
listeners receive 25
off your first order go to
outstandingfoods.com whitney or use code
whitney at checkout to claim this deal
that's o u t s t a n d i
n o dot com slash
with me what books have changed your
life or movies or like
pivotal you know yeah yeah yeah and then
not me actually thinking about it no you
don't let me give you time i hate it
when people spring that shit on me and
then i'm like renee brown
i just say whatever the most basic thing
is you can say even though i love
brene brown but i have this thing right
now that she's gotten popular i'm like
mad at her
i'm like that was almost like that was
our thing i'm like that will almost yeah
like cardi b i was like that was our
little inside joke
that was like how i felt about making
the stallion where i was like
everybody's listening to her now oh yeah
like i i was there from the beginning i
used to tell people to put her on at
parties
like this like we're friends you
abandoned me
for the main stream i really loved the
princess bride
oh big one big one hans labyrinth was a
big princess bride
that showed men should serve
women and polish their saddles here we
go
go rescue them here we go and obsess
over them and take care of them
and even the old witches even with the
witches
yep yep um my
my my parents were like um i don't know
there's things that i know like are
seminal that i just like didn't
watch like um like big important
cultural things that i just like didn't
grow up watching but they were like very
specific things because my dad really
loved like
old movies and westerns um the way that
he like describes it is like he's like
we didn't really get anything in nigeria
but if there were
too many reels of something that's what
we got and so he grew up watching a lot
of westerns and like bollywood films
but i love like old clint eastwood
yeah westerns like the good the bad the
ugly i could probably
say like like recite it like forwards
and backwards fascinating
a hundred thousand times i mean my dad
always see
because in new york there's a theater
called metrograph and they have like a
dad's
father's day lineup and so we always
catch like a western on father's day
but so i i loved like westerns growing
up and like old kind of movies like that
um uh clint eastwood was the mayor of
sir yes for like a few years but
apparently i just went up there
apparently they're like yeah he became
them
he wanted to build a house that didn't
uh
like line up with the rules zoning
zoning so he became the mayor so that he
could change the zoning laws and build
the house and then he just like
built thousand got out of there i
and apparently he leaves at six o'clock
every day a car no matter where you are
in the scene no matter where you are in
your coverage he's in the car at six
o'clock and gone
good for him yeah and i think sire at a
child at what like 70.
he's a madman he's i think he's a madman
yeah he's not well he's not well
yeah the last couple of movies i feel
like have been a little tricky
a little tricky gran torino is tricky
it really is that energy where it's like
all right you you go on your last
livestream yeah yeah yeah
yeah like maybe maybe like who like no
one loves you who's telling you to just
like call like maybe
read did anyone read that script before
he shot it like i'm just curious like
that's my thing with woody allen i'm
like he had to go
so long ago like who was reading that's
the thing i think nobody's reading
he's casting me he's like that's true
that's a good
when we try to get something made
there's so many people saying i don't
know about this i don't know about this
and i see shit like that i'm like
no gatekeeper yeah got it got it cool
love it
this is fascinating clint eastwood
princess bride
and then i really i read a lot of books
as a kid i remember
like i could read when i was really
young
um like when my mom says i could read
when i was
three i don't know if that's totally
true or if i was good at guessing but
she says it's true so i believe her
but i just was always like trying to
read but i don't even know if i read
like
good things because when i go back in my
childhood library it's like
all like books that are like dog
anthologies
where they always die at the end is my
guess yes yes like a lot of like
sounders and old yellers and like
scholastic little characters like
12 stories about dogs
so i was reading a lot we don't know if
it was good like do i have to kill my
own dog at some point like that's what i
grew up being influenced by sorry
sorry i'm gonna take you to the forest
with my dad and he'll shoot you at some
point well uh i remember reading
fucking where the red fern grows and i
was like when people were like the
phones are so toxic i'm like nothing is
more traumatizing
than us having to read for summer
reading where the red fern grows
the the shit you have to put up with for
summer trauma those books were
traumatized absolutely insane
and then what if you could like remake a
movie because you're going to get these
i mean if you're probably already
getting these kind of opportunities like
you're going to get
like so the thing with you is not about
what you're going to do it's about the
order you do choose to do it again
i start weeping yeah yeah you should
normal just crocodile tears just like
smiling just full
like marilyn monroe like i'm dying
inside my shoulder and you're actually
like why am i saying this
i i am afraid because it's like the
thing where we learned like to just say
yes to everything for so long and now
you're gonna
you're gonna have to say no to most
things even say i've gone to a point
where
i've said you should have said no to
this podcast but you didn't thank god
you're still codependent
yeah no i rely on you don't get too
healthy
but where i'm like i said no to somebody
i knows podcasts because i was like i'm
really stressed at work right now and
then i was like huge
texting my friend i was like i feel like
a horrible person i don't want this
person to think i think i'm too big for
my britches i just can't do their
podcast
because if you're not going to do it in
five years when they're still fucking
dragging that thing across the finish
like have you taken a poo today yeah
like you're really pinned up
like it's okay no one is
mad no one is mad and the only thing
that would be worse is that if you
showed up to someone's podcast
not wanting to be there and being like
resentful and then you're like
i forced you to do something i didn't
want to force you to do right
and now i'm not everybody's moving now i
raped your time
but you showed up yeah you know what i
mean like i i
i'm always like you can say no if you
want to please don't ruin our friendship
yeah don't let me ruin our
let me do this yeah yeah i love whenever
anybody said no to our podcast i'm like
i get it
i love it when people say no because
then you know where you you can always
trust them
yes if someone takes care of themselves
in a relationship you can always trust
them like
if you like i always know where i stand
with you and i can trust you yes
a hundred percent 100 i know that you're
not like operating out of like obviously
no it is good to like get a sense of
people's boundaries like i'm always
afraid of when somebody's like i have no
boundaries and i'm like
well i have one i have a lot of them i
have one
that is here with you people say it like
they bragged like i have no boundaries
it's like why do you say
that yeah oh tell me your red flags we
always do this on the podcast red flags
because i do i want to i know i have to
let you go at some point but
you're i loved your um this um sketch
you did on comedy central
uh uh that i think was like it was about
like
the digital getting ghosted or something
like about like all these like terms
about guys and like how they
treat you yes and it was meant to be
like very stupid and we were like
but it was so smart in a way that like i
always like to go like i'm finally at a
point where i know what all this fucking
shit means
and i love talking about it i don't know
not to be like whatever like it's
a sketch for kind of central digital but
like you know it was a thing where
it's kind of like i think you could look
at it face value and be like oh like
here are these like young girls
obviously making jokes about dating
trends but like it was us being like
we're making fun of the way that people
talk about this yes and the way that
people think that young women talk about
this like
we're playing that up as well and the
way that
sometimes women enable other women
by accident i know it comes from a place
of love but you're not being a good
friend when you're like no no he's just
like yeah too much yeah
he likes you too much he's scared of how
much he loves you
yes and he there's some must be
something off with his phone like maybe
he's on a plane there's wi-fi on planes
now
so it's like i feel like sometimes we're
trying to help each other you're perfect
and he
you know what he like doesn't text a lot
that's like a good sign exactly like
calls
no and i actually saw him like sleeping
with another girl actually i slept with
him and i think that is oh my god
that's even better because compared to
her you're gonna be so much better you
need contrast
this is like the best thing ever he's
gonna
people are allowed to be bad to your
friends don't pretend
this guy's because then she's like all
right right don't force your friend to
be in a bad relationship
whenever one of my friends is a bad
relationship i'm like do you know what i
need to get you we need to talk about
your
girlfriendships i'm not mad at the guy
anymore at this point i'm mad at your
friends for allowing me saying
i don't have any expectations for him i
knew but like what's going on with your
friends how do we help the whole friend
group right now they know
because we're hurting we're hurting as a
group is there any like major red flags
i always like to pass these on yes yes
yes i do think
um no boundaries is one yes for me or
i'm like you should have
boundaries like how does that make that
present itself though like uh
where you where a guy will literally be
like i don't have boundaries
i've heard that before i've heard that
before
maybe this is like the eight there's
also like i don't know what does that
even mean
or like the age of like the sensitive
man i think the guy i think that's a guy
trying to have emotional intelligence
and they like heard that
on oprah and like just said it they
heard like half a sentence on like
a half a podcast when they were like
skipping past the ad
but then they also and they also are i
think they think
that's attractive to women i have no
boundaries yeah like i'm like
my heart is open like i think they think
they're being vulnerable when they say
that yeah
and it's like no you just know you're
just being scary i have no boundaries
like i'll jump into anything with anyone
i have no boundaries i'm in four
relationships right now like huh
it's a weird brag yes it is a very it's
a weird
i don't here's what i like that is a red
flag to me when people
friendships or relationships where
someone says something about
themselves that is a character defect
i'm just going to use that word
uh and they say it so that if they do
something shitty later
it's your cover because i told you i
told you this is how i was i told you i
already told you and then
if you keep seeing me after i told you
all this stuff what's going on with you
yes
also feel another one for me is like how
do i explain it because you know
conversation right it's like
you do relate to each other and you swap
stories back and forth but when you
realize that somebody can only
be like wait i actually know what this
reminds me of and then they just like
say something about themselves that like
is
barely tangentially related like you can
see them like
just trying to relate but they're
uh chronically addicted to
only making things about themselves and
like relating them to themselves i
uh i had an issue with this myself yes
oh yeah yeah i'm doing exactly what
you're saying
but you're not like when my dad died it
was like i realized people were just
like you can't talk to people all the
people whose dad said
our parents had crossed over suddenly
just reached out they're like do not
talk to anyone
who hasn't had a parent die suddenly
they will not know what to do because
that's my dad just died the terrible way
oh my god my praying mantis
didn't drink water like lost a leg in
the
yard and you're like not the same i had
a
uh family member died
and i remember telling a
friend at the time and when i told her
like i was like so in shock like i just
got the news and she was like right
there and i remember being like
oh my god like my family member
like died and immediately she she looked
at me and
burst into tears and it was like i had
an eating credit
and i immediately was like it's okay
did you have an affair with them like i
said you're two bits
like should i is there anything i should
know i mean it's
when you have someone pass you spend
most of your time taking care of other
people
cause you're like oh my god i can't
believe this is happening and you're
like no i'm okay
i know i'm okay i promise what can i do
to help you nothing you just literally
you take care of yourself yeah it's
so i thought you were going the
direction of like my family just died
they're like
well starbucks is out of soy milk so
what are we you know when they try to
equate
their trauma with yours she cried
that's what she wanted she cried she
really felt it she felt like almost
i just need i just need a minute it's
just that one of your family members
died
[Applause]
and this was your your friend my cup my
cousins
it was incredible it was really
incredible to witness what i will say
is um when something like that happens
when someone else acts like a dick there
it
i find there's a little bit of a nice
respect cause i'm like okay i can think
about you being a dick instead of this
thing happening there's a little bit of
thank you for giving me a little break
from the pain yes to think about how
dumb you are
it was something like a little bit after
i was like she gave me a gift like she
gave me in this time of grief an
anecdote of distraction she gave me a
story
and a story and not everybody could say
that is it possible that you're the
asshole in the story
it's always like well you get to go make
money off the story
so why are you psycho totally anytime
something terrible happens i'm like oh
well i'm gonna go make some money off
that yeah
yeah totally so it's like who was it was
saying that like um
uh if comedians were molested it's like
taking steroids and sports
it's like it's like someone's like
melissa it's like okay now you're just
cheating
like they're just bragging i once had i
knew somebody who was like
i hope you don't use me in a joke and i
was like
i would never fucking give you the
satisfaction but i am going to tell
every other
every person i know and it'll be a fun
little story was like i hope you don't
put me in your act i'm like
i won't because you've never been funny
could you do something
funny yeah if you if you could sort of
like be interesting
yeah like maybe say something worth
repeating at some point
i just don't like you that's it yeah
yeah yeah no but well the best is when
someone tells you like the longest most
boring story and they're like
you can have that thanks so much
to throw away thank you that's going to
be my new opinion
waste yeah you were talking about like
the line at taco bell
i'll take that and now you were rude to
the waiter this is gonna kill
come you're coming on the road with me
everyone it is it is pretty wide when
you go home now that now that you're
like a
known comedian make money doing comedy
when you come home
as everyone's like oh like no my family
is so rude i'm good good good
that's why you're funny my family's so
rude i'm not even funny in my family
um and also my like especially i'm
like i have cousins who are just like
very like high achieving and good at
their jobs
and so like i'm the little artist
obsessed like
that's it i'm like i'm the little
jokester do you guys have lisa kudrow's
brother
is the biggest migraine doctor like in
the world
you see that's that's why he was like
the hit at thanksgiving
that's where i'm at where my cousin is
like
yeah so anyway like i just like started
another non-profit
in nigeria and went home and like just
like helped all these kids like how was
um
like i got a show on quibby how was like
um what is it the show with like the
about talking about like teeth right big
teeth
um like yeah man like yeah yeah it's
pretty good still on
air i slept right he's like awesome so
anyway like i got these children wait i
have to put in a password to watch your
show okay i probably won't watch it but
i definitely like
good luck do you know brad pitt
yes and you're like no and they're like
okay okay
like anyway like it's just sort of it's
that it's like if you are you're only
famous to your family if you
know an a movie star or um
they've seen you like a hollywood like
walk of fame
yet if you've been only on a cable show
they're like hey can you cover my
mortgage and you're like
so you must think i'm i know you know
something's popping
so what so tell me the math no i'm not
famous yet you're
invoicing me for 80 grand every week
like so which is that
right because you're able to to not know
anything about what
what the fuck i do yeah you want me to
buy you a car
so where where are we on this it's like
it makes sense
i just just make it make sense it's so
like paypal requests yeah you've never
seen my show
copy yeah so i know that so i went um
one time
oh sorry no i just did go back home to
nigeria once and i did have like
my grandmother's sister was like
so you pay for the compound or what do
you want to buy me a bag
and i was like i just met you this is my
first trip here what do you mean
what do you mean i am buying you land
i mean honestly i'm sure you've gotten a
couple gift bags that you can just ship
down there
let's not let's not okay now you are
being just being
she
i mean we definitely get said shit
forward on i can send a box for you you
know like like i said a promotional blog
promotional box like all the shit we can
said just poured it off
they're like wait who is this wait is
this your show it's like
oh because we get stuff for shows now i
remember that nicole kidman thing came
out
they sent me like all this rant like
phone charger
no it's crazy like i'm like i should
just send this on it's gonna be
confusing
airpods for something i didn't even work
on so i got the raycon speaker
and i sent them it's like it yes it has
my name engraved in it but like what's
the problem
uh like a polaroid camera for one yeah
well then i was like i'll just give it
to my mom that'll be nice and she was
like
how do i work this here's just a
polaroid she was like why do i want this
we stopped
using these i know i like yeah like all
right
it's so funny how and i know like trying
to do a good deal hipsters it's such a
but it is a little bit like hipsters now
use the same technology as old
no it is funny that like record players
are coming back
my dad sent me a text where he was like
do you want some of my old
records and i was like actually i don't
have a record player first of all
i've ever dated
and dead um and ultimate cancelling then
when you sent me the records like i
realized like
you know i don't know there are people
who it's like my dad had like the first
pressing of
the beatles white album oh fuck my
awesome fucking dad and my it's called
the white album it's the white issue
you can possibly listen to it um and
he he sent me like pictures of the
wreckers and they were like oh like
you know musicians i'd never heard of
like there was an lp by a group called
the fat boys
that was like this like rap trio
and it was like this song like don't
kick my nuts
i was like no i don't want this i
promise you i don't want
these right if you gave that to like a
hipster
the big oh we're going to love this band
no genius you're really lying
it would give you like passed around
like to some guy who like ghosted me
who's like now
in like a band that's like mixing with
like african
found sound like new wave and then it
was like charlene's my best friend i met
her once
it was there's like this guy called
william oh yeah neighbor who is like
this
this artist who had like a resurgence he
has a song called like atomic bomb it's
kind of cool but then
the guy from like the hot lips i think
and like
damon albarn they like they like did
this thing where they were like
we're rediscovering this man and paying
him
what he was due and i remember being
like yo dad like you're from nigeria
like did you know this man and i was
like
yeah his music wasn't that good right
everybody's everybody's on it now so we
love we love to see it
that's so funny to me it works i just i
love i love the i
like when i was like dating and having
to go to guys houses
and i would just see like a typewriter
and like polaroid cameras yeah i was
like you're not going to be able to film
good stories for me and that's how i
make my money on instagram so
like this whole letter i think this
seems real cute but can you use dropbox
like i'm going to need you to show me
how to use final cut pro like i know you
have like a celebrity
resume what are we doing i get it you
can use a record player
cool but like can you film like
something for my podcast when i'm in a
jam
yeah that's the unless of you like i
love your like old camera collection
like that's super cute but like can you
work acrobat
adobe reader can you help can you help
film the cake top
put me on tape for an audition for a job
i'm never gonna get yeah and send it and
it goes through without the little red
minus
can you help me can you help me almost
book whatever you do
like you're in the mix for the next
thing can you help me get in the mix for
the next job
that's going to lose fun there i was not
told during a general once they were
like we've been watching your
tapes that's like chilling yeah i just
wanted chilling tonight
was it me tapes it wasn't me yeah who
was that
wait a minute you've been watching and
you're smiling but i still haven't
booked
help me out no okay no generals you want
to talk about boundaries no generals no
generals no generals
all right for what for like a cat you
know
they're like oh i wanted you to meet
casting or wherever at something oh so
so come in and meet me uh so that you
can envision me
as the character yes she can meet even
more with me
come in so that when when my name comes
up you're like oh my god she's so
amazing but like not ready for this
she's
so nice anyway um look at this hot girl
it's cold to julian that's why it's
called acting so
let me come in and act the part because
if you know who i actually am the
acting's gonna feel like you gotta hire
me though yeah what if you just like
gave me a
job i'll take it i mean i really would
take it
like call me in like try me
you know i want to start i want to do a
thing where actors are like i'd like to
take generals with casting directors and
producers to see if i want to work with
them
and you should though i feel like
powerful people just start doing that
isn't that what powerful people do like
i just want to meet you i don't know how
power works yeah you should do that you
should start being like i want to take
generals with directors and see if i
want to work with them um i've decided
that you can set me up on a general with
um martin scorsese i just said because
it's also like the idea of like they'll
be like oh no why would i drive over
there without a guaranteed gig
two hours and then sit with someone that
hasn't chosen it's like
yeah that's what you've been doing to us
for like a minute now
we're they'd always turn into like weird
dates it's just like we can
it can even be like a one day thing it
can be sort of like take your
child to work days like dating yeah yeah
it could be a week like a book fair but
with humans
we could all have um they used to have
that for um naca does that still exist
for comedians and i know that's like
dude i didn't get booked naca is like a
showcase
i just i felt like a genuine you would
do a rumble in my stomach
i really just remember well i have to
pee so bad after like right now that i
can't tell what's going on in my stomach
um i'm currently boarding and so there
was a
i couldn't get booked there because i
was too edgy of a comedian
because i like dared to talk about my
vagina or something and a lot of
comedian a lot of
uh colleges are like christian groups
like bring the comedian in so i was
never a match but they're like but
you're
45 minutes clean baby but you could come
in and stand in a kiosk and pass out
your headshot
and just try to just charm people so i
went to naca
who was on the lineup it must have been
like kyle cease dmitry martin
steve byrne steve hofstetter like i can
fucking
remember this shit and then i stood in
the kiosk with my head shots and people
buying my like hey i'm a comedian and
like
i'm not allowed to be on this but if you
hire me like i can do jokes about this i
do jokes about dating i do jokes about
like it was just like
peddling your wares yes incredible as
like these are the ti
this is my stick
[Music]
that's book number two yeah it's just a
brew like it's like whitney
cummings1.net couldn't get windy
companies.com but
i'm working on it like it's not a game
the humiliation yeah that it's no it is
it isn't
it's professional humiliation last thing
i want to ask i know i let you go i say
last thing and that
it's never true uh what shows did you
watch growing up
oh because you have such a specific type
of sense of humor that i'm obsessed with
i watched a mix of
um i was always at some sort of old
person's house
so i was always watching like especially
i remember this one
at my church i almost was like i don't
want to say her name and dox her
no one knows that she is her name was
sister raquel if you could find out who
she is from that name
yeah just show up you deserve
yeah you deserve a kidnapping she's a
prize that's my thing
when someone's like um uh like i have a
stalker i'm like i'm at the point where
if someone can find out where i live and
come like
you deserve to kill me at this point
like you're my like i like i'm
all day like you're so resourceful that
i want to be with you
i know i need that energy in my life yes
um go get her
with the camera i always have on like
pbs so i watched a lot of like
um murder she row and masterpiece
theater
and like old monty python sketches
i remember i loved monty python so much
i thought the spanish inquisition sketch
was the
funniest thing i remember trying to go
to school and
telling everybody what it was and they
were like bitch we're watching that so
raven what are you talking about
literally what could you be talking
about um so i watched a lot of that
always had on like tv one or bt
at my parents house um or like any other
black channel so like uh amen
and 777 and like those
like you know good times plus like the
martins
and i mean the wb lineup the
maliciousnbc
and then i loved um like
the ones like i love those i love bill
bellamy's
who's got jokes with the music video
that he released when he was a singer
for a hot second
yeah yeah yeah yeah he loves bill bill
here's that no i still do he came in
audition for something i did and i
lost my shit literally elections were
the people that if you
saw them like you'd lose your shit a
little probably bill bellamy yeah yeah
definitely definitely robert towns i
think we could make this happen
there's like a level of like black man
with a mustache yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
dude imprinted steve harvey's book act
like a lady think like a man
legitimately changed my life and i
made fun of him when we did a live
comedy stream together and
he we had a weird like i've had a lot of
weird interactions and i know he's very
polarizing
but that book is like a secret like
weapon yeah yeah yeah that nobody admits
to
it's like scientology for dating no one
will admit that they're they fuck with
it but it's like it's
it literally is like wear a skirt like
it's so
sexist and fucked up like just let him
open in the pickle jar
like yeah just let him do stuff i know
that my mom has it and for some and i've
never
read it but i know my mom has highly
problematic
works very well i'll check it out next
time it's so
toxic and i'm just like it's it's any
man that's ever loved me is because i
read that book yeah of course
i tricked them but those oh and like
anything on nick at night i loved like
interesting
sitcoms like i really did as a kid and i
like
saw every episode of like nanny and
golden girls who if you saw them you
were just like there's a couple of
people that i've met
that i just like walked away yeah like
and was like
get away from me yeah yeah yeah type of
people who who are those
people mine was like margaret atwood sam
jackson i panicked when i met him at the
roast of quentin tarantino
i literally looked at him and i just
went oh my god i love you so much and
you know when you're so nervous you just
say what you're thinking
and i asked him i was like how much
money do you have
and he told he was like you mean like
liquid like and then we got into
conversation
and i was like oh my god i don't really
i just was thinking it and i'm so sorry
about all this
i um when i met tim robinson for the
which was also it was so fun like i
didn't think i would have that reason
yeah yeah yeah exactly when i met him
for the first time i literally could not
speak
and then because already i was like i
think this guy is cool
and then he was like oh i think your
instagram is funny and then i was like
well i did you and when you and yeah i
think well if you have a good
day then that's the day you have yeah
it's gonna be a good one well
and and unfollow me now please
now that i know you follow me i'm never
gonna post again yeah no no when i
admire someone a lot i'm kind of rude to
them
i think i'm kind of the same way though
where i
where in my head i'm like i'm being like
deeply rude
i'm trying to play it cool but i'm
actually being like really insulting
which is my thing about when you meet a
famous person or someone you admire
don't be like hey what's up like i don't
want to be that person who's like
like groveling over them but you're now
just being an asshole i think i
yeah i think i i i
i yes i absolutely think i do that and
that probably needs to change because
but to me the the the
i it just varies so wide wild but your
dream you're gonna have a movie that you
can star in who
is in it who's in it who's in it who are
your heroes i like
a lot of old weird ones oh my god you
just watched you're just
working at a like nursing home with a
bunch of old people and then all white
man directs it like this is going to be
like you're like like dream of mike lee
is busy with his british people
that would be really cool or like a
charlie cough man or like
a pta yeah this is also like my dream
where it's like they wake up and they're
nice and who they tried to come for by
the way
no it didn't cat then didn't take well
it didn't take everyone's like did you
see punch drunk love you sure
okay some things can't take but yeah but
i don't know i just think there's like
some people
are like because i think paul thomas
anderson is the type of director that
would make
us better performers yeah yeah yeah
because it's not about like
pushing right like they're just like
their style
yeah it makes you see a side of actors
that you can't see anywhere else
yeah my dream will be like him and then
he gets like daniel day lewis out of
retirement
to play yeah he stops like cobbling
shoes
i i have a theory about daniel day-lewis
everyone's like he's retiring i feel
like he's preparing for a movie where he
plays someone who retired
that's genius it's genus and it's
probably true okay well he's a retiree
he's like seventy
yeah i work at the nursing home yes
we get into like i don't know hi jinx or
whatever the hell
yeah yeah um and there's other cool
actors there yeah yeah
clint eastwood could be a 90-minute joke
to get off his lawn
yes yes exactly we just get everybody in
before they're
before they're ready to go last call
okay so i have this relationship the
movie is called last call i want to do a
movie
i randomly met what was his name in
spokane
lorenzo llamas
okay so the fact that you know that is
why so lorenzo llamas
comes to my one of my shows in spokane
his
girl girlfriend her fiance is a big fan
the club manager comes back and like
slips you a note
it is like funny it's like lorenzo
some soap star from greece is here and
i'm like oh here we go
he comes in i'm like i recognize this
guy like i feel like
he's like that kind of 80s soap star
handsome i'm like i know this person
comes in
halfway through i'm like are you lorenzo
llamas
and he's like yes i'm lorenzo llamas i'm
like dude didn't recognize you without
the duster
he's now a pilot a fake like a
helicopter
he's a helicopter and a job but imagine
he's not acting anymore he's now just
doing the thing he wants to do but
everyone gets on the plane and are like
this is most actors though where they're
handsome and i'm like
i feel like you should be like a really
handsome like
um like like gas station owner or like
you should be like a mechanic imagine
getting super famous in one thing and
then you're so famous you can't
you can't do your dream has wanted to be
a therapist her whole life
she goes to psychology school she said
that people come in like are you susan
or they take appointments just because
dude i got to see what susan lucci's
like as a therapist
so i wanna do a movie where it's all
people that were famous in like the 80s
and early 90s
that went on to their other career and
no one will take them seriously so they
start a commune
where they all get to do the jobs that
they really really want to do
and no one treats them like they were
famous that's incredible
so it's only like like b-list
celebrities
as like every job get fabio up in there
and they get the eggs he makes the
butter spray
yeah yeah yeah or whatever that is the
butter guys
and everyone gets to live out their
dream because it's with other
celebrities that don't
see themselves yeah but then it's like
it has to kind of implode because
nobody's getting like attention or
something
or one person gets called for a reboot
and fucks it all out yeah yeah
yeah you know what i mean and it's like
the main it's like the pilot and so they
can't get off the island
because lorenzo llamas gets a reboot for
whatever show he was on boston common or
whatever
and they're all stuck there because he
got that reboot money
i have to be so bad i am obsessed with
you
iconography yes big mouth yes
it goes on and on dickinson she's on
apple tv
on dickinson yep i don't even have a
subscription i can't even watch
people are so charmed by you you come in
as a writer and they're like will you be
on the show please uh maybe
maybe something like that yeah twitter
you might not get it
but just know if you don't get it you're
wrong i know i have to be
i have time okay grace take over and do
promote all the things okay
we need to promote okay my socials are
my name
which is io a debris a y
o e d e b i r i and you can just sort of
um
sort of search from there i feel
i feel amazing great and come on and i'm
gonna make you come back
this is just the beginning of a very
entrenched codependent partnership
[Music]